The Joe Rogan experience podcast by
night.
I need a new song.
It's time.
600 episodes.
I think it's that you haven't had that
for the first hundred.
Yeah,
whatever.
500 maybe.
It's great.
I love it.
I used to like the,
uh,
tell Nick Diaz that if he doesn't win
then you've got to get a new theme song
because I will never take his,
his voice off the theme song.
We'll do a neat new theme song and
incorporate his voice.
That was the one of the coolest moments
in my life.
You kidding me?
He's got his hands up in the air.
It's like train by day Joe Rogan podcast
by night.
I was like,
that's the coolest thing that's ever
happened to me next to the birth of my
children.
It's right up there.
Wow.
So,
uh,
we're all here because we're friends and
this is an intervention Dunkin.
I know you thought this was a podcast
masturbating.
You're gonna.
Have to tell them about the demons.
Tell them what happens when.
I don't know if we know those Jews.
Know that when people masturbate,
they're actually fucking beaman.
That's on top of you that you can't even
see when you come.
It comes into her belly and you have
demon babies.
The only way to get the Jews out of my
body as to jerk off Jews really bleeding
and the only way to get the juice out of
your body is a jerk off.
Oh,
you have to get possessed by demons and
they swell up in my chest and they
caused my penis to expand and to change
shape.
You know what I'm talking about?
When inside of a shape,
it's very strange.
I've seen that comes like this.
Tape up marshmallow guy so you get
demons to sexy movie.
The only thing that gets the demon out
is if I jerk off a Semitic man,
then when I do that,
I see the demon come out of my penis in
the form of this white,
salty substance.
Either it goes back to normal.
Your penis stays like crazy,
crazy aggressive.
It's always screaming howling at night.
So we're here.
This is not happening.
The new show on comedy central or should
fear officially a baller,
just had his new comedy central hour
special,
paid regular and that was the coolest
shit man.
The comedy store was tweeting photos of
the red band tweeted some to of the
patio,
the field.
Everybody out there watching your
special on tv while you were performing
in the or.
That was the craziest picture.
Jeff Scott Show Shit onstage live at
this store and on standby special was
from that same stage and you know what's
even cooler?
People come to see you now.
I think your new material now.
Some of the best shit you've ever done.
It's right up there with the best bits
you've ever done.
The new show that you're doing now.
That stuff you did in Vegas.
It's fucking great man.
It's really funny.
Shit without telling anybody to have it.
Say a good eight minutes.
Eight minutes.
That's all right dude.
Keep swinging.
I'm really good about 40 right now,
but it's 40 that I don't.
I don't know it that well.
That was still a ever evolving like
these,
like Jarvis Jarvis,
Jarvis.
He's just say the bits where like,
I'm like cooling metal or cooling honey,
so it was like real fluid and then as it
gets cooler it like more and more shape
until it becomes like the same thing
every time.
It's cool.
Yeah.
I remember that.
I never,
I don't remember total talent
coordinator.
You told me that.
That's an interesting way to look at it.
I've always felt that they grow though
always felt that there are living thing
and it becomes sturdy.
Like they started off as like little
saplings and they're like,
oh,
sometimes they look impressive and
sometimes they come.
Sometimes they come out,
they're fucking trees.
There's certain bits that I've done that
we're already a tree before they ever
got to the stage,
like the Vegan bit.
That was just on my last special.
I wrote that bit all after one
conversation.
Did you name that bit?
Jamie Kilstein to Jv.
Kelsey and Jamie Kilstein,
believe it or not,
even though he talks a lot about being a
Vegan,
he's not preachy about it and he also
admits it.
He ate a lot of meat.
He's a bad example that Jamie Chelsea
gets a bad rap and part of it's because
the conversation that he and I had on
the show,
but he's not,
he's not a bad conversation.
I don't remember if he's out there
listening.
Jamie Kilstein.
I think you're a good dude.
I really do.
I think he's a,
he's a genuinely like what he's trying
to do.
He genuinely thinks he's doing really
good things and he's just,
it was about the um,
the Daniel Tosh rape thing.
Daddy touched me that joke where he
asked the audience what they wanted to
talk about.
Some guy yells out rape and Daniel Tosh
start saying like,
oh yeah,
what a great subject.
Like,
what's so funny about rape is it,
the humiliation is the violence.
Some woman says,
actually,
nothing is funny about rape.
And he goes,
wouldn't it be funny if five guys just
rape her right now?
And it became this big,
sent me.
Well,
first of all,
that's the kind of shit that happens at
a goddamn comedy club.
No,
we all know that.
And the guy's just trying to be funny
while he's on his toes.
On a stage in the spur of the moment,
that's what to me it's like a non issue,
so jamie and I disagreed with it heavily
because he felt like the lazy and he
felt like your contributed to rape
culture,
which is a term that gets bandied about.
It's a.
it's a weird term.
Some people think it's horse shit term,
you know?
There is no rape culture.
The real thing.
That's why if you say the Indian comics
from India and stuff,
they're super rape joke.
He comes out and they're consistent gang
rapes.
No,
that's all.
That's pretty much all our comics just
talk about rape and gang rape and then
it
really in the ecommerce peters from
Houston,
they're Indians.
They're brown is fuck barrier.
Our Indian garment for sure,
until they have a seat stay.
There's giant movie industry.
Their movie industry is bigger than our
movie and Super Porny,
right.
It's not always long sex scenes and
those considered juggling a fruit and
singing in between a gun fighting movies
still have a musical numbers where they
will start in the middle of a real
action movie.
When I went to,
we would take volume and go to this
movie theater in New Delhi and just
watch their movies because there's so
trippy.
But yeah,
in the middle of like an action movie,
uh,
it'll stop and do a musical number that,
like a real serious action movie.
Why?
It's just their culture did like it.
They like it.
They like that style of to will mean we
used to like it.
And if you go back and try to watch
those old Oklahoma,
well all those,
like gene Kelly movies,
there was start dancing in the streets,
but he would stand there and people
would dance around them and they had
music videos at broke out in the middle
of a movie.
So they have also applied to put it.
Yeah.
They have all these plots.
They have real language.
They're real dialogue.
They have a real storyline.
You see like why there wouldn't be
singing about,
well,
it's someone's desire,
the one person's desire in the middle of
a gigantic performance where people are
interacting with each other.
It's one person's desire to totally
steal the spotlight.
And the best way to do that is by saying
everybody has to stand around and listen
while John,
like we're all like support.
We're in the back and John's in the
century snapping.
Yeah.
And he's got this great point and we're
all like,
wow,
yeah,
senior angle above live and everyone's
letting him move around and nobody stops
and go,
what are you fucking doing man?
Like why are you saying like nobody
interacts with them.
There's no interacting.
It's just this one guy,
which is what the theater to some folks.
It's all about that moment on stage
holding the stoll.
Who Got Paul?
Reminds me,
man,
I got a million dollar idea.
What's a found footage musical like this
found footage?
Movies.
But they find one where like people are
actually real music.
You know,
music is playing.
They just start saying,
hey,
like what?
The flare.
That will be great.
Really bad songs.
But Linda's choppy video,
it's totally happening right now.
I've got another.
I've got a great idea to do with it of
an improvised musical reality show,
but they gotta
do it.
That's a great idea.
That's a great idea to bring them into a
situation and the audience doesn't know,
so they have to.
They're are people going to interact
with them to sing out to this restaurant
or bar?
Have you ever seen the video?
There's a video with this bringing you
back to a activists that get that.
Sometimes ms dot point.
There was a video of this lady,
she steps into a chicken restaurant and
she starts talking about this is not
food,
this is violence,
you know,
and there's a little girl and her saying
and she just wants to live.
She just wants to be happy and she just
wants to live and this little girl was
going to die just like all of her
sisters and all of her brothers and her
family chicken a chicken and she rescued
this,
this chicken.
And so she just like videos of the same
gal with her chicken at home,
you know,
it's like.
So she goes into a restaurant and
disrupts all these people and like tells
this whole story and then explains that
it's hurt our chicken and then a whole
crew of assholes come in behind her with
signs.
This is not food.
It's violence.
It's so weird.
And they're like,
we're just running a restaurant.
Did it seems like a parody.
It seems like someone is just bad ass.
Some Tim and Eric type dude really just
put together some bad ass parody that's
so subtle.
You like not sure like is this bitch
really this crazy that she's referring
to this chicken as her girl?
So it seems sometimes that like
activists aren't aware of the fact that
if they're stumped isn't pulled off in
the right way.
It seems like it could be more
detrimental comes off course,
you know,
like people will,
their response is going to be too rude
to eat more chicken people.
Yeah.
Just because you're like,
I don't want to be associated with this
kind of behavior and if that means
eating chicken,
then I guess I'll eat more chicken.
So it's like it's,
it's dangerous to be an activist if you
are not really subtle or if you're
aren't skillful in what you're doing.
Like being an activist is awesome.
Just make sure that you're graceful when
you do it
well.
Not only that,
you have to have a real objective sense
of what actions you're putting out there
and how those actions are going to be
perceived.
If you fake it,
you can see through and it seems lame.
Well,
there's some people that have this idea
that their idea,
what they're protesting against is more
important than anything that's going to
disrupt anything that's going to involve
that.
Like Greenpeace Greenpeace did with the
Nazca lines.
Oh yeah.
They fucked him up so fucking crazy.
He's dumb ass holes.
Went to the Nazca lines and they set up
a graph,
looks unethical,
Nazca lines.
So these,
they don't even know how old they are.
Okay?
There are thousands of years old.
These law.
Meanwhile I'm like,
because we know how old they are.
You just revealed that you're an
immortal.
They've dated more than a thousand
years.
Whatever it is.
They're all sorts
of geometric patterns,
animals,
all sorts of different things.
Some of them are animals,
some of them are spiders were all these
weird patterns you can only see from the
sky patterns.
Okay,
I'm sorry.
So there are patterns that are in their
patterns are made on these flat plains
and some of them are just a bunch of
rocks that are pieced together in these
lines and people have left them
undisturbed because they're so cool
forever.
So you can't just go there and walk
around on them.
You can't fuck these assholes went there
and they use some of the stones as
paperweights.
They pick some of the rocks on the
ground or they go to sign up this
fucking stupid green peace sign.
Oh,
see that?
Pull it.
You got a photo of it,
Jamie?
Put up with Dick's.
Yeah,
but so douchey.
And because a lot of what Greenpeace
does is really good,
which stop people from killing whales.
Remember lines of just.
There's photos.
Jamie go to photos.
Greenpeace Nazca lines the seal outside
of a store.
GRANDPA's.
So look what these assholes did.
See,
see how cool that that design is,
that pattern,
that pattern has been there for.
That just naturally happened in the
time.
Oh right.
And they were,
they were using stones from that to put
their sign with the,
with the foot thing.
So they weren't disturbing people.
I don't know what the fuck they think
they're doing.
They're still disturbing it by doing
that.
Like sometimes standing on that,
look,
you're fucking footprints are also in
that paper.
I could see the bottom of your tread.
You know what that means.
That means you stand.
You stood on that shit.
You stood on that shit somewhere and I'm
supposed to believe that you're doing
this all ethically.
You're not fighting fire.
They shouldn't have done that.
It backfired.
And that sucks because all the people
who are doing good work look like
assholes.
Exactly.
That sucks.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this is,
this is the actual of those are the
lines like that?
Yeah.
What makes them.
We don't know.
They don't know who made them.
They really don't know that shit.
Wow.
That kid.
That's not,
that's not just like movement,
like a kinetic movement.
Right?
Oh No,
no,
no.
These are mad that someone.
Definitely.
Without a doubt.
Is that in sand or is that in stone?
This is so funny.
Some people think that the geometric
ones could be indicated flow of water
that's connected to rituals to summon
water.
Spiders,
birds,
plants.
Could be fertility symbols.
Other possible explanations include a
irrigation schemes or giant astronomical
calendars.
Why isn't everyone trying to figure it
out?
That looks like a bird.
Yeah,
well they're definitely trying to figure
it out.
There's a dog.
There's a monkey.
The monkey.
No,
pull up the monkey.
Jeremy.
They're so good.
There's a date.
There's a sport.
There's this binder that looks like.
What's his name?
If you,
you'll find you'll find a monkey down
there and there's a monkey and one of
them.
It's really cool.
It's got like A.
There's a,
there's birds which bird feet and shit.
There's a gang of.
I didn't bill cosby and ecstasy get
makes them like that.
It's weird to see the images that
people.
Do you remember when they used to do
that with a.
whether they would code certain words in
the websites.
It's like a person that porn porn porn.
Funny,
funny.
People think it's an alien.
That thing,
that person with the eyeball,
so click on that.
Well,
yeah,
but I mean that's how my daughter draws
people.
You know,
everybody says it's an alien.
It's an alien.
Well,
maybe maybe somebody might be a giant
two year old,
might be really shitty artists for
thousands of years.
The shitty artists,
the jetty.
Like I had this conversation with this
dude who was trying to tell me,
but you know,
these images on cave walls,
we're,
you know,
aliens,
depictions,
valence like Graham Hancock,
who I love.
But it was like,
come on man,
I might not be an alien.
That can be a lot of shit.
These people,
if they want to believe in,
and not only that,
but it was thousands of years ago.
Just what they saw back then was aliens.
That's when they pull up the monkey,
Jamie,
and you just see this monkey see monkey
because it's really cool.
It's got a curly tail is go down a
little bit,
go down a little bit more and more and
more and more and more and more.
Start up a little up.
We got it.
It's gone.
It was a dog to the left.
Do you see that?
One of the far left,
Jamie.
About three down.
Oh,
it's okay.
Just let's try to find a monkey.
Whereas that monkey.
Where's the fucking monkey?
The monkey from us?
No.
Well,
if you go to the Wikipedia,
you could see the month.
Here's the cool.
Here it is.
So it's like it's puking or it's on the
wikipedia.
If you go to the Wikipedia,
look at them like,
oh,
that'll look.
You can see it there.
It's enormous.
How big is a person to toe?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
That's a very good question,
but they're really big.
I mean you,
you see when those people were walking
around,
I mean digitally,
they were laying that out.
It looks like it was drawn like with a
finger on a tablet or something.
It doesn't look like a shit ton of
people spend a long time look.
The tail kind of wore out.
They've had some damage with mud slugs
to apparently.
Yeah,
they.
But they,
they really.
There's all sorts of explanations,
but nobody goes there.
They just look at it and then the
Greenpeace people want.
They're aliens came,
visited these people,
gave them like showed them some
incredible shit.
They left.
The people want them to come back.
So they draw these shapes on the ground
and hoping that our attorney,
it's classic cargo cult behavior.
That's where it all is right in the same
place in Peru.
Yeah.
This one area,
it's really fascinating also because
there's what looked like landing strips
there as long parallel lines.
They want them to come back.
That's what it is.
That's got to be.
Doesn't have to be.
It could be.
They just know.
They just figured out how to draw it in
the ground that you can see from the
sky.
Maybe they just thought it was an
interesting way to do something that
they couldn't see your will.
They could.
They just couldn't see it really well,
you know,
you can only really truly see what it is
when you're up above it,
but I mean it's not impossible that they
could measure it and do it all on the
ground.
I'm just proposing being the devil's
advocate,
like it's not impossible that they did
those.
You could see the ground.
I mean,
you're looking down at your feet.
It's not like you're invisible to you to
help.
You do like 12 mile wide monkey sabic.
They're not that big.
They're a few hundred feet wide.
I think the really big ones,
but there's not like 12 miles long or
anything crazy.
Maybe I do it the lines themselves or
they're superficial.
They're only 10 to 30 centimeters deep
and could be washed away really.
So that's why nobody goes there because
I'll wear it down.
It's only ever received a very small
amount of rain,
but there's issues also that the great
changes that we're seeing to the climate
that it might start raining.
They're not fucked crops.
Well,
at least you know,
everybody's like really hooked up crops
ever,
but everyone will be better than the
stupid lines.
Right.
But everybody's really localized.
They have it in their head that,
you know,
this,
um,
that this site is like,
it's super important.
But we have all the images,
like once we have the images,
if the water comes in,
washed everything away,
at least at least we've documented.
We know these people made these things.
We don't know why or when,
where they think it's the nascar
culture,
which is like,
I think it said here,
400 to 650 add.
So they lived there and maybe carve
those things they think.
So that's over a thousand years ago.
That's,
you know,
more than it as,
as much as 1500 years ago.
Go to work and show it could be longer.
Crazy shit man.
They don't really have any explanation
for why.
But there's a lot of.
I mean,
you could,
it could be aliens,
right?
I mean if we can go to Mars,
man,
we can send a robot.
Tomorrow's.
It's so arrogant to think that we're the
only ones that could do that.
I've never seen any evidence whatsoever
that's even remotely compelling that
aliens have visited here.
None of it.
That's outside of other.
There's not one thing that stands out.
We say that had to be aliens.
It couldn't have just been really smart
people.
Now one thing and why would any of them
left anything?
Well,
it might've.
It might've when,
when we're looking at the pyramids,
when we might be looking at is someone's
knowledge and information from another
culture.
Well done.
The pyramids somehow point to serious,
serious sort of,
sort of.
Well it depends.
He said there's a thing called the
procession of the.
So the earth spins.
Yeah,
right.
You know,
it's like,
it's,
there's like a wobble to the earth and
so when you see this,
the stars,
it's not always the same and it,
it wobbles like,
you know,
every x amount of thousands of years.
So depending upon where you think these
were constructed,
you would have a different star line.
You'd have a different thing that you
would see.
There is a guy named John Anthony West
who's just amazing when it comes to this
shit,
his whole video series.
It's called magical Egypt.
So good if you've never been.
I mean it's like if you're not even
interested at all in Egypt,
like,
yeah,
that's fucking boring.
Bunch of people living in the sand like
assholes if you want,
if you want one of these videos.
I would love it if I was high.
I was just trying to be funny.
I would say that.
But um,
his videos are super in depth about the
construction methods and how big it is
and like all the magical things about
the way they built them,
they think that it was a culture that
lived a long fucking time before.
We think not just like $2,500
per se,
but like he's of uh,
the,
the notion that it's like 10,000
plus BC and if you go to 10,000
BC apparently where the lion is a
sphinx,
where it's pointing would be directly
over the Constellation Leo.
Oh,
I like the serious theory.
Better the dog star.
It's like Robert Anton Wilson.
Crazy idea that,
uh,
that we are possibly currently existing
in the serious star cluster in what
we're having this experience of reality
pumped into our consciousness as a form
of training for something like Matrix
pods,
and that there is like,
so there's like clues left in the
simulator pointing back home and just to
just as a little cookie like you even
video games,
you know,
or maybe people a long time ago or more
aware of the fact that this is a inner
interdimensional academy at kind of
hogwarts for young God links who are
trying to like,
who have the potential to become like
universe creators.
But before they're elise to like create
their own dimensions.
They have to go through this infinite
loop again and again and again until you
learn that the most important thing is
to love the people around you more than
you love yourself.
And then boom,
and then you can be a god.
Well,
yeah,
then you can then we can trust you to
fuck around with like our black hole
machine or whatever.
I'm not going to put you in charge of
black holes while you're a selfish
shithead.
Yeah.
That always seems to me like if that was
really like a plot,
if someone had designed like people with
this sort of like puzzle in front of
them,
the plot is eventually they're going to
get intelligent enough to figure out the
plot.
That seems to me to be like a really
shitty way of doing things.
There's God that's like various.
Tell them how do it.
It's very godlike.
Yeah.
It's very good.
Lord.
Eventually just tell me that's the only
way to teach kids in that sense.
Eventually that confusion that people
feel of the existential angst of being a
person.
We don't know what the fuck you are.
Where are you going?
What happens when I die?
Like almost universally that needs to be
plugged up.
Whether it's plugged up with this alien
story or whether it's plugged up with a,
you know,
a Mormon story.
What happened?
You just got to plug it up.
Yes.
That aching feeling of terror that like
some people that's meant that.
What are we doing here?
What are we doing here though?
I understand they,
there's a,
there's a great,
uh,
existentialist philosopher slash author
Khumbu.
You ever heard?
Of course horse.
I haven't heard of.
You haven't?
No strangers.
One of my favorite books.
I love them.
Yeah,
you'd love him.
But here's the thing.
You just did it yesterday or was it the
day before?
I can't remember.
That's the first line.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's really good.
But he liked that thing that you're
talking about that at aching fucking
thing.
His premise c,
a m u s his premise in a lot of,
uh,
of his ilk,
their premise is that,
that,
that is being human,
like that awful feeling of like having a
whole that you are constantly trying to.
That's the name of his book.
The Myth of sisyphus.
The stranger illustrated is a novel.
Let's try the myth of sisyphus.
If you want to get into the philosophy
Anglo,
but uh,
it's pretty,
it's pretty cool stuff,
but it will give you that chilling kind.
Sufis s y s is there another wine there?
Assistant s y s y p e h u s fuss as if
it's beautiful.
I don't really need to totally know
that.
Google next to be on the kindle crack
crack.
This specificity was cursed.
It's a Greek myth,
was cursed by the gods to eternally push
a boulder up to the very top of a hill
and then to let it roll back down the
hill.
And when it gets to the top of that
story,
is that like the Colonel Turner?
So the,
so like the excess,
some existentialists look at the human
predicament and they point out the fact
that you're going to die.
No one will remember you in a few
hundred years.
All,
most human achievements that have
happened in the past are completely
lost,
gone,
forgotten.
Even though they're in history,
it's still ultimately a meaningless
thing in a sense that you have this
inevitable personal extinction that's
going to happen.
Uh,
and so the predicament and life is one
of being sisyphus.
Here we are.
Anything we do,
push it up the fucking hell.
It's gonna like roll back down.
We got to start over,
push it up the hill,
roll back down.
This is the kind of human archetype for
how do we,
in the midst of what appears to be
meaninglessness and the infinite scale,
find meaning in an in like human
endeavors.
When the whole thing's going to get
wiped out by the star,
the sun.
Some of those philosophies have brought
them to God.
What's that?
Some of those existentialist that
brought them to God because there were
like,
this must be the answer.
The access.
There are weirdly,
there are theological or theistic
existentialists,
Soren Kierkegaard.
There's some of them are,
and you believe in God.
We're start.
Yeah.
Then they're the ones who are just like,
no,
it's just all nausea and confusion.
My friends,
it's just a lot.
I don't buy that because I don't buy
them knowing.
I don't know anyone that says no.
It's nothing.
Nope.
There's nothing like,
how do you know?
There's nothing.
You have no idea where.
There's no examples.
There's no price for something.
You're right.
Don't even bring it up,
right?
You don't bring it up,
but you don't say no,
but you don't.
You don't say it's not something either,
but are you land more in that camp,
don't you?
It's not even part of the conversation.
Get out of here with that shit.
What is what a fish were once there?
Well,
if you look at the fossil record,
is there any reason to think that
otherwise,
what are you talking about?
I think there is.
I think there's reason to think that
Fisher bears or whatever the fuck you
want to think if it gets you in the zone
because there's like a.
that's like taking two dribbles worth a
shot.
Like it's just like ritual,
ritual.
It makes you feel better.
That's fun thing you just described.
The two dribbles before the foul shot
that the that's called chaos magic.
That's the roots of a magical system
that just that it's based on the idea
that these symbols themselves,
they lack any inherent meaning outside
of the mind state that they place you in
and so if they help you transform your
will into reality,
so if that ritual helps you score,
if whatever the fucking thing is that
you do prior to sitting down to write or
prior to whatever it is that your job
happens to be,
if that actually puts your mind in a
state where you are more likely to
receive inspiration or you're going to
be more graceful or athletic and that's
all that fucking matters.
Who Cares?
Yeah.
That's all that matters.
Who the symbols themselves,
do you.
I mean,
are you really going to like worry over
the actual existence of a elephant
headed god?
That right?
It can shrink down and ride around
family unit over at Rosewell and it's
like,
oh,
they've fallen out of the issue is a
belief system as much as the issue is
getting caught up in an ideology that
you can't question.
That's because when you do that,
if you want to go into thor camp or
whatever camp you want to go to and you
believe is the,
you know the grand ruler of the fucking.
Yeah,
no matter who it is.
In the name of God,
Odin,
renter,
praise,
Odin.
Praise Odin.
Yes.
Anytime you can't question anything,
you're fucks bill.
If you have something you believe
that's probably empowering.
It's not empowering is when you
subscribe to an ideology because if you
believe that there's some all eternal
loving God that's looking over you and
judging you everyday and that you have
to do your best to make him proud.
That is your divine father.
He created you and you know,
deepen your DNA.
What the good things you're supposed to
do is if that if you really go live your
life like that,
you'll probably live a pretty fucking
cool life.
Yup.
You'll be really nice to people.
You'd be super righteous.
You would want to make your daddy God
all proud of you and shit.
The problem is when you subscribe to an
ideology,
and that doesn't let you question
anything,
the problem is not believing in a god.
The problem is now what do you have to
do?
Because you believe that God,
well,
now you have to stop gay marriage.
You have to stop masturbating.
You have to stop people from doing this
and stop.
Yeah,
you gotta.
You have to listen to me because my way
is the right way and the Lord is the
true Islam is the truth.
All of that stuff.
It's all the same shit.
The ideologies,
the problem.
It's not the believing in God.
What does this motherfucker God want you
to go?
Do you want me to strap dynamite to your
chest and walk into a cafe,
but God gets associated just like you're
talking about the chicken lady.
God gets associated with that,
so you want to be like,
no,
fuck them and fuck the thing that they
believe in.
Exactly.
Well,
yeah,
it's like a guy that.
What happens is there's violent people
in the world and they like to be
violent.
They enjoy it.
It gets them off,
but they can't rationalize the fact that
they enjoy being violent because it's
seems so monstrous and animalistic need.
You need a reason.
See,
their religion is a fantastic way to
justify every dark activity that humans
engage with.
Yes.
You can fucking like.
Did you see the thing that popped up on
the Internet?
Isis is guide to having child sex
slaves.
Did you see that?
Like I have a guidebook which is like
they have questions like there's
important questions.
If you have a slave that's under aged,
that's a girl and you're wanting,
or a,
I guess a guy,
I don't know.
I guess they don't like gay people.
So if you have an underage sex slave
that's a girl and you are an isis,
you're going to have some questions.
The number one being,
when do I get to fuck her?
Yeah.
And this is a guidebook where they're
like,
well,
can you fucker.
Well,
if she's able to have sex in this
guidebook,
it's as if she's able to have sex.
Uh,
yeah.
But if she's not,
then you can enjoy her in other ways,
like just don't penetrate her.
But that's a real thing,
man.
They put,
they're putting that in there
quoting,
how do we know this is real and how do
we CIA plant?
We
don't know that it could be an.
I did think that this could be
propaganda.
I thought that this could be propaganda,
but they do.
There are taking slaves like it is a
thing that they are taking slaves and
some of those slaves are women and if
you have a female slave that you've
taken,
that you've captured from your enemy,
then you are going to have some
questions about the role.
Like as a religious person.
Definitely.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
What are you going to do with your.
How do you ethically fuck this girl?
Like when like when the dishwasher was
invented,
Jews had to go to the rabbis and said we
allowed to put milk and meat dishes in
here.
What's the ruling here?
That shit,
that kind of logic.
They use that based on,
in a second.
Are you,
uh,
what is the answer to that?
A lot of Jews have separate dishwashers.
Dad,
Syria,
lariat conflation.
Oh my goodness.
If you want to be kosher.
Yeah.
The main thing is the main thing is
this,
right?
What the.
I mean it's awful.
It's like the sex slavery isn't as
ridiculous as that as the structure is
always the same,
which is a very manipulative,
charismatic power,
hungry narcicisstic guy has convinced
some dumb people that he has got the
line end God and as long as they're
coming to him to ask him what to do,
it's great.
That's the main structure.
The structure needs to be that have
certain amount of people believe that
there is one person who has contact with
an invisible guy and that that that
person will tell them what's right and
what's wrong.
It's very comforting.
We don't have to worry about it.
You don't have to worry about it.
Just go to the guy and ask him like you
can feed her moral quantitative figure.
Yeah,
but it's so dark,
but really when you see what's what,
what's happening,
there is this incredibly awful version
of snm it sadomasochism you're going to
your daddy to find out how the fuck.
It's like this dark say to mass.
That's what it is.
It's snm.
You're going to your daddy to find out
if you can put milk with whatever in
your in your washing machine,
you're going to daddy to find out if you
can use birth control.
It's always set.
A lot of times it's sex related.
Like the pope just said something like,
didn't you just come out and say like
you don't have to.
He was talking about how to have sex.
You know,
they'll tell you you can't use birth
control.
You know that.
They tell you things involving sex,
like a man who is connected to an
invisible being will tell you how to
fuck on this planet.
What I mean it is stupid.
It is as dumb as it gets,
but when you consider the fact that it
is,
not only is it real,
but it is like these people doing this
are behind businesses that are making
billions of dollars every year and that
money is going in the direction of
paying for lobbyists to control
government and politics.
That's when it becomes minister
government.
Sinister.
If you look at it from a picture
perspective,
do you think it's possible for people to
have gotten where we've gotten as
quickly as we've gotten without
religion,
without some organizing ethical behavior
was the big jump early on now?
What's holding us back?
We're back then it was really helping us
like guys,
guys don't kill.
Well,
we would be raping and pillaging.
Still.
There's a Judeo Christian way of living
they say,
which is just like the basic tenants
like don't murder,
don't steal,
don't,
don't rape.
Well,
it's almost like an idea virus that is
introduced into a system in order to
force growth in a certain direction
because I never would have gotten
society without a doubt it.
I doubt it.
Dudes want to fuck the Greeks.
People want to rape.
Yeah,
but they had a gang of different gods,
but I think they were kind of like Greek
gods.
I think even back then they were.
I think even back then.
I don't know for sure.
You know what?
I'm not even going to that part of me
that likes to chime in as though I know
anything about Greek gods to come in,
have no idea.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I'm not really sure about that man,
but I do think that it's a.
The predicament that regardless of that
being,
whether that was a kind of cast that
needed to be placed on humanity as a
whole to allow this growth or this thing
to do.
Now we're in a place where we've
outgrown the cast time to take off the
cast.
It's starting to smell like a.
like somebody sneezed into erotic
vagina.
Well,
it's being replaced with a new one.
It's being replaced with atheism.
Atheism is very much a religion,
but we take those tenants of like,
yeah,
we got killed.
We lost that one.
I don't mean it in a negative way.
I mean it's like religion is the wrong
word.
It's an organized group.
The people that are a part of it,
they.
They subscribed to the ideology of this
organized group and or almost like for a
large percentage at least,
I shouldn't say almost the majority,
but a large percentage or liberal,
a large percentage of atheists are
liberal people.
They tend to lean left with their ideas.
I would say if you had to gauge the
difference between the Republican side
and there were Democrats are like,
which one has more atheist?
It would clearly be Democrat.
Right?
Is that right?
Am I guessing?
I'm just guessing.
I don't know.
Let's see if we're right.
I'm sure that's been done.
That's.
Yeah,
that seems pretty logical to think that.
You mean it does seem logical,
but let's see if it's true.
Also the more into their super into God.
The Republicans might have some
atheists,
but the ones that are super undergone,
those are more Republicans.
I don't really know.
Could you be a single president?
Is that even country?
Nope.
The candidates of the president.
You can't be like.
No,
if you haven't figured that out.
I hardly think.
I was wondering what would happen like
if Obama as a president allowed to have
another job like in Obama start like
working on comedy.
Could he do stand up if he wanted to at
night?
If he wasn't working at better could.
That would be amazing.
I've done my job.
It's 6:30
PM.
I worked an extra hour.
I'm clocked out president.
A lot of the people in Congress are
closeted that are atheist closet.
That's hilarious.
Wow.
What a bunch of fucking fakers it's
saying there's an article about this on
a progress.
Why all of the atheists in Congress are
are closeted.
That's.
We'll say it had to pretend like you
can't.
It's not popular.
Atheism is not unpopular.
There's a certain thing that people want
to do.
They want to say something really stupid
and have everybody else go you like,
we're not going to think anymore than we
already.
Yeah.
When people say,
well,
I'll tell you what,
I meet somebody and they're an atheist
walk way because they're a damn fool.
Who said a Steve Harvey.
That's right.
I did it in a white boy damn food and it
gets silly.
Silly,
silly,
that's an argument,
PJ Harvey or whatever it was,
kind of moral compass.
Do you operate on them?
That's the idea.
I can't trust you if you don't believe
and assemble.
That was created a long time ago by
people trying to control other people.
This is like silly,
so forget it.
There's a book I read in God dammit.
I wish I could remember the name of it,
but the very first chapter in the book
was talking about how fascinating it is
that in the old testament when God is
asking for offerings,
yeah,
killed only want stuff that humans like.
Like he only wants the best thing.
Like God never tells priests to ask
people for like a jar of wasps.
It's only,
it's only like goats.
Like now the same system worked.
Then the priest would come out and be
like,
God wants.
They do money.
That's what they do.
The fucking people,
Jimmy or whatever his name is.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's.
The difference is money now it's this
ambiguous thing,
but back then what was kind of
interesting is like you would actually
ask for like the fatted calf or you'd
ask her stuff was only stuff pad.
God wants a new ipad.
Technology.
Yeah.
God wants a.
don't let your computers.
Yeah,
it's very.
It's fascinating that way.
But I still.
I mean I do like.
I don't know.
I think God's an overused word,
but I do think there is definitely like
I don't know what God wants.
He didn't really tell us officially.
How about,
how about we just give him some of this
shit.
It's our favorite shit.
Yeah.
Just get on the ice,
man.
That's really fascinating stuff.
I've been reading this book that I know
it's a controversial book and some
people say that it's like,
I don't know.
I liked the book.
It's well written.
It's called a zealot by Reza as la land.
It's the historical Christ and his
premise is that Jesus,
the regardless of its premise,
what's really fascinating is he just
talking about what it was like back
then,
which is that the Romans had,
were occupying,
um,
that,
that land and that the priests were
actually people who were used to be used
to be like a religious thing,
but they were by their positions from
the Romans.
So everybody wanted the Romans gone.
And so.
Oh,
right.
So like,
you know,
in the story in the Bible,
Jesus is crucified between two thieves.
And so Reza Aslan says that if you look
at the actual word for thief,
it actually translates into bandit and
bandit is the word that the Romans used
to describe people who are trying to
overthrow them.
So Jesus,
his premises was somebody who was pro
violence and wanted to overthrow the
Romans.
And there were a lot of other people I
came to.
And so when people were saying they were
like the son of God or the Messiah,
the Term Messiah actually meant like the
King of the Jews.
Somebody who is going to like lead the
liberate the Jews from the Romans.
It's a really great book.
In the very first chapter,
title,
it'd be a cool fucking movie.
It would be really cool,
but the version of when they talk about
the the same,
well they weren't.
No,
I mean a lot of like what he says is
like if you read in the,
in,
in the,
in the Bible now they haven't scrubbed
all of the violence.
Debbie said one thing he said is like
something about I will turn you away.
I will turn,
turn father against son.
I will turn like,
if you aren't able to leave your family
then you'll never be able to follow me.
It's like all these things which are
crazy to liberty is fucking Romans Outta
here,
man.
That was the idea.
These assholes are occupying our
country.
They've taken over our religion.
We're going to fucking overthrow them.
And they really couldn't understand why
God let the Romans in there in the first
place.
So that was a real monkey wrench in
their ideas were the chosen people.
But it's like,
no,
you're not really that fucking chosen
people because they're guys who are
guarding your temples now wearing Roman
outfits.
And mine's got freedom from slavery that
we're sorta half slaves again quickly
and they couldn't tie.
Didn't work,
man.
It was like the to the paradigm did not
fit in with their idea that we're the
chosen people.
Suddenly there's these fucking Romans
occupying everything.
And so a lot of the,
these messiahs and there are many
besides before Jesus,
by the way,
John the Baptist executed.
Why was he executed?
He was executed because they looked at
him as a threat to the Roman power
structure.
That was it.
All these people getting crucified.
And by the way,
man,
crucifixion was in back then,
like they were throwing people on
crosses every day.
So it was like,
it was like a constant attempt to like
take down a rebellion.
That's it.
Silence the rebellion.
Yeah.
I silenced the rebellion.
It's really interesting.
Great Book.
It's really crazy.
But those sort of volatile moments in
history,
crazed insane violent moments of control
and then the repercussions of that
control,
those are like the engines that fuel
change and oftentimes fuel innovation
and I know we'll look at them as being,
yeah,
we look at them as being as like
horrible moments when they're happening
because they are for everyone involved.
But like for the future,
like the,
I think all these chaotic moments where
these people struggling to get into a
position for power in the fact that
nobody could really hold it and it keeps
and people have their complaints and the
people that are rising up,
they have the will of the people because
the will of the people is we don't want
any as fucking terror anymore.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All right,
let's go get them.
And then they get in and they become the
person that we're fighting against.
Like this process repeats itself over
and over again.
And it seems like objectively,
if you look at it,
it's this process of cleansing or
filtering,
almost like water coming down from a
glacier and going through all those
rocks until it becomes pure.
It's like,
it's got to go through all these trials
and tribulations.
There's got to be all these fucking
chaotic moments of horror.
So we understand what har is.
We never repeat her.
You got to have a holocaust,
understand where the sixties came from.
You've got to have these bad moments
that sort of make you like long for and
accomplish the great height.
This is why I,
I just had Alex Gray on my podcast and
I'm not going to try to repeat what he
said about the Jews,
the chosen people because they're
creating psychedelics,
but he did one of his premises because
Hoffman was a Jew.
But when will,
the idea is that we needed scientific
materialism,
atheism.
We needed people to turn their backs on
the ancient version of God so that we
can understand the universe at a deep
enough level to be able to,
uh,
create the,
to synthesize lsd and all the various
smart to figure that shit out.
Yeah,
it's really cool.
But it's kind of what you're saying,
which is like we needed like these
phases in human evolution are really
important because like if,
if you,
if you're constant,
if you're caught up and are ridiculous
version of the deity and then maybe
you're not going to be so inclined to
study molecular biology or maybe you're
not gonna be able to study chemistry in
the same way and without studying that
stuff,
then we wouldn't have some of the
psychoactive compounds that I think a
lot of people consider as being one of
the potential ways that our species can
evolve.
And so these,
these,
these psychedelics can actually be ways
to connect with the thing that the
ancient religions were talking about.
And then the thing that ended up being
like turning turned into like a painted
clown,
you know,
that people will.
Somebody had a vision,
you know,
Moses by that.
What was the burning Bush Bush,
what was that?
What was it made of though?
It was called a Acacia or something
which has what in it?
DMT.
Tryptamine.
So the premise here is godliness
fucking hurt.
Well,
the idea of what is,
what would the story really big?
Well,
if you're translating something from
ancient Hebrew and then you put into the
Latin and then eventually the English,
what when you're doing that,
you're going to.
The way they explain things is going to
come off very different.
Like if you ever read like Russian
story's translated to English.
There's.
It's so bizarre.
Yeah.
Throw it through Google translate.
It's so busy.
It's so hard to understand what is their
language works so much differently.
So by saying that like God took the form
of a burning Bush,
they easily could be saying he was
smoking dmt.
That's right.
Easily.
Yeah,
and that's the fucking answer.
You dry the fucking that Bush out.
Figure out a way to get the fucking dmt
out of it.
You smoke it.
Like if you.
And especially if that's how they did.
Like what if they just lit
those bushes on fire and then just read
it all in,
some out of it.
Just breathe in wholesale smoke.
They did it like totally caveman style.
Just take those bushes,
hack them down,
dry them out,
make a fucking a tent,
like one of those sweat lodges and let
it fill up.
Hot herself with dmt and then he saw God
was like,
dude,
everybody down there.
Hold on.
I got.
Oh my God,
I got some stuff to tell you.
Oh my God.
Because God was telling you that not to
covet your neighbor's wife,
not because your neighbor's wife is like
his leaves my life while was alone.
The idea was that the guy owns that
white.
Hey.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Like this insane archaic way of thinking
that's connected to that time.
Yeah.
So we don't even if Moses did say those
things,
we have no idea what the actual words
that came out.
If Moses did have this psychedelic,
ancient,
he was not used anymore.
And not only that,
like who the fuck wrote it down?
It wasn't Moses.
Moses didn't write it down.
If I told you some shit that happened to
me when I was a child and then you were.
It was your job to write a book after I
died.
Oh,
you would butcher it.
I would put your,
your life,
you would butcher Milo.
We would butcher each other's lives if
Moses wasn't writing it himself to
Moses.
Yeah.
You know,
if you're not getting his fucking
notebook,
like who knows what was actually said
but jealous.
Written the same way throughout history.
Like they write every letter the same
exact way.
That's the written tour world tour or
something crazy looking,
by the way is a language that's cool.
It's beautiful and it's so strange and
psychedelic.
They have to have a musical notes on
each one of the letters.
You can really,
you know what to go up and say it while
you're reading at the Toro road or
partial.
Can you read Hebrew?
Of course.
Fucking crazy,
man.
I'd like to learn it.
You lived in Israel,
religious studies.
Was it fun?
Yeah,
I can.
I'm going to have.
It was just like a given for awhile,
but now that I look,
step back and look at it,
I was like,
that's pretty fucking cool.
Three weeks.
I thought it was cool.
I lived in Israel for two years.
Wow.
How old were you?
18.
18 to 20.
So it was all that got drunk there for
the first time.
Pre,
post,
pre pussy.
Wow.
I haven't do anything back there.
That's a fast.
So slowly take the buses and stuff.
What's it like there?
Everything's made of stone.
Jerusalem.
The whole city made up stuff.
The old all stone.
But everywhere else is like stone
outside,
you know the buildings.
It just looked really pretty.
Did you go to that wall,
climbed up in that movie,
you know,
security cameras.
Why Monitor to the wall?
Separating from a mass of zombies
dancing and having a great time and then
all of a sudden it's not fine.
Yeah.
He escaped to easily a lot in that
movie.
Like plane crash and then only the two
of you survive.
It's like Godzilla.
Same sort of situation.
But.
So you were there from 18 to 20?
Eighteen to 20.
I really got drunk for the first time.
I was like,
what years was that?
Well first I went.
My high school does it half year for
senior year.
The second semester,
second for six months we go to Israel
and we all get tour groups.
That was the foods.
It's really two and a half years.
So one year and calendar year was this
[inaudible]?
Ninety two,
I think.
January of [inaudible] 92.
So this is like Clinton presidency,
Bush.
I voted absentee ballot for Clinton.
That was the only time I ever go to the
president.
Did you were religious garb while you
were there?
I mean Yamaka and the tassels man,
one thing we love doing because there
was no black people there,
only Ethiopians and they were like in
like a different part of the town.
I'm of the country,
um,
who just yelled nigger already each
other down the street.
Oh no,
because it doesn't mean anything.
Doesn't mean anything to anybody.
That's fascinating.
Scariest word.
Every.
Yes.
You'd have to do like a full three 60
sweep of your surroundings with a
helicopter parachute down and yell it to
feel super confident.
Someone was like the only word that you
can yell out and the group is allowed to
punch you.
If you yell at people.
Women can't just run up to you and punch
you,
you know,
but if you didn't yell out Nigger,
they have a free pass.
Just punch.
You want people to know this.
The only racial slur that that is a free
pass to violence.
Yeah.
Chinese,
if you yell out change now look at you
like you motherfucker,
you piece of shit.
But there are certain dudes,
not all of them,
but there are certain dudes that if they
catch you yelling out that word,
they will fuck on Prophet Mohammed of
words.
What?
It's crazy.
If you're in a place,
I mean there's guaranteed.
There's people that just heard you say
that,
that are going to be offended.
They're like,
you know,
fuck that guy.
You know who?
Fuck he think he is yelling at shit out.
Dropping bombs podcast 22 years ago.
No,
it doesn't even matter.
Just the fact that you had just said it
now,
right?
Just the fact that making fun,
that how irresponsible.
What's to say that you remember like the
bit about the three magic words and that
was one of them that like,
you can't even say it,
like you're not even allowed to say the
word reference to if your weight.
Yeah.
It is a really interesting thing because
symbols are harmless,
but it somehow they justified violence.
Like whenever this ridiculous thing and
image of the prophet,
the word round,
whenever it's there,
it's like that thing itself is
meaningless.
Harmless.
But it allows,
it allows violent people an excuse to be
violent and there is nothing I think
more satisfying than some people,
uh,
to,
to be violent and righteous at the same
time.
Like American sniper that guys like
pegging like,
oh,
it's just some propaganda over from
kills.
Not One role.
Even though every time it was like,
I don't know what that is,
is because man,
fuck it.
I'll tell you the shot.
Never got it wrong.
Oh,
awesome.
Oh Rah Rah movie.
Yeah,
it was,
it was really exciting.
Was horrible.
And you seen it?
No.
Howard stern was raving about it this
fuck you old man was a horrible job.
There was no plot,
it was just some scenes.
The wife was only annoyed.
I haven't seen entire time.
She was just like,
are you going out there?
And again,
he'll give.
Never built a relationship.
There's no fucking move.
You haven't written this fucking movie.
Don't give a fuck at the very edge they
go,
they go that he,
okay.
So he comes home,
he's all fucked in the head.
He meets some,
uh,
some,
his wife,
he meets some veterans.
It helps them fucking sniper and that's
how he gets his life together,
helps them sleep and shit.
And then he picks one guy up and he's
like,
yeah,
we're going to go snipe today.
And then,
uh,
just at home on the range and the guy
looks at his wife weird and then it cuts
away.
It goes,
uh,
he was killed by a veteran.
Oh,
is that guy?
But they didn't even show what happened.
They didn't even show up to our 20
minute movie show every tour fucking
forward toward combine them,
but they won't show.
Forget that they failed to mentioned
that your son or your daughter and they
showed footage of the funeral
procession.
Also.
The guys like Jesse Ventura sued that
guy and one the guy who lied.
Yeah,
that's how ridiculous it was.
There was no.
It wasn't just dad.
Apparently a whole long laundry list of
questions.
That was that guy.
No wonder Carbon Jasper.
They probably didn't take out the plot
like A.
Well,
there was a bunch of other things that
he did that he said he did.
Like one of them was,
there was a car jacking or two people
shot and killed it.
Read like a fucking men talking about
himself.
Apparently that's how I saw no evidence
of the car jacking.
Took that guy to guy and there was
another one where he killed a bunch of
people in Katrina.
He was a sniper and Katrina would shoot
shooting looters and talked about,
which is like,
okay,
like it's one thing if you're shooting
terrorists who have rocket launchers,
but you're shooting people that are poor
people that are stealing shit because
they're involved in chaos because the
fucking water has come and surrounded
the city and there's no resources and so
you're shooting looters like it should
be really fucking careful about who we
celebrate.
If you're shooting looters,
yeah,
you're a murderer.
Yeah.
We're not talking about war.
We're not talking like even Michael
Moore was talking about his pollutant
though.
That's not what you get for Luda.
You
don't get that from God.
Damn.
It's not made for people who want an
agnostic for a judge to say,
well,
it's not only that,
it's not the fucking roof.
It's going to be delivered because you
go to a trial and you have a jury of
your peers.
That's what.
That's what the government is supposed
to be established for,
like to be on a rooftop.
Then you're just murdering.
This movie was like a full liar.
Crazy.
Well,
Jesse Ventura fucking navy seal.
He was in.
What's called the Udt before it was the
navy seals,
I believe that's the name of the
organization.
There was a predating name.
The same.
Jesse Ventura was one of them.
Yeah.
So apparently this guy told the story
about knocking out Jesse Ventura and
Jesse Ventura badmouthing the troops and
bad mouth no more,
which he said he would never do,
never did,
never argued with this guy that he never
got hit.
And he gave the guy an opportunity to,
uh,
to tracked it.
Otherwise he was [inaudible] he wrote
about in his book he called them scruffy
face or something like that.
But then on radio shows he admitted that
it was Jesse Ventura,
so can do the math.
I think he did it on Opie and Anthony.
Actually,
I think that's where it came out.
So they realize that it's not true.
So the guy got killed.
Okay.
Chris Kyle gets killed and now Jesse
Ventura goes through with the lawsuit
with the guy's wife,
which that's.
See?
No,
she's got all the profits from the.
Yes,
fuck her off the fucking lie about him
her.
Then she started saying,
I give that money to charity and then it
comes out later.
She's a liar too.
She kept 20 percent of it.
I think as long as her look,
if her why should life isn't.
I mean it's,
he's suing the guy who lied.
It just so happened to the guy who lied,
died,
let's stop selling the book,
but that's the issue because you're
dead,
right?
You're dead.
I'm going to the issue on the book.
Random guys like who owns the book?
Who put but.
But then the issue is does he represent
them when he goes on radio stations and
says something that's not even in the
book.
Does he name the guy in the story in the
book,
but does that make them responsible?
I say it doesn't say it's not random
house because he said scruffy face with
a.
But then when he says,
now I've told you it was graffiti faces.
Now what you've printed label or
whatever is the thing man,
if he wrote about all that other shit
about shooting looters and all that
other shit.
Like if that turns out to be not true,
which people are saying it's not true,
you really got to take the whole book.
Took the book off like this is what's
important to separate had that book,
but the shattered a little pieces or
whatever.
A thousand little pieces.
Yeah.
Yes.
He was like,
no,
it was all a lie and she was like,
what?
Because again,
I'm a fucking kid.
He just said he went to heaven and he's.
He came out and said the whole thing was
a lie.
You know that?
Yeah.
They pulled that book too.
They went to heaven.
Well,
no,
there's this cheesy buck where a kid
goes into a coma,
flies around having for awhile,
comes back right to this best seller.
People are like,
I knew everyone was real and I knew it
was like this.
I never read it,
but it's funny.
It's just the La area,
but the kid got religion actually got
religion was and felt
so guilty about wanting that.
He came out and said the whole thing was
alive,
that I could get attention.
It's not real great.
It's really,
it's the Nicole that there's a great,
there's a great blog that I read called
a if you just google truth justice and
the curious case of Chris Kyle.
It's really,
really well written.
I wrote which explains all of the
various stories and here's why they
couldn't be true and here he's not
casting a judgment,
not using the inflammatory language.
Just trying to explain like what may be
or may not have been true said in the
beginning of this movie that was just
released.
This is all a true story.
Some of it I'm sure was.
That's the thing,
the guy that the shoot some kid and they
go like,
if you're wrong about this,
you'll find that your spotter spotter is
telling you you're going to go to jail
forever if you take this wrong shot.
Another thing you have to remember too
is Clint Eastwood,
Clint Eastwood,
who used to be the baddest motherfucker
and I'm done now.
He's an old dude.
Talk to the chair.
Yeah.
You are dressed.
Obama.
Yeah.
How do you direct a movie?
When I saw the thing?
No,
seriously,
when I saw the thing.
Oh,
I thought was,
oh,
this is just clearly wartime propaganda
tweeted that he considered,
he compared it to the sniper movie and I
Tarantino's movie,
I think Rogan backpedaled a little bit,
but in Tarantino's movie inglorious
bastards there watching this in Germany,
they're watching a movie about a sniper
and it's being celebrated propaganda.
It's propaganda.
American sniper is propaganda.
There's no question about it,
so we know that.
Then I was thinking like,
oh,
let's make this shot of Clint Eastwood
really direct this because when you see
him at the Republican National
Convention,
he seemed kind of like out of it,
so then I was thinking,
how the fuck is this guy directing like
this kind of hardcore action forum and
the vase there because he's this manly,
rugged,
right wing Republican hero,
and they knew that that would like get
more people to watch this movie,
which is essentially a lubricated water
slide that leads to your nearest
recruiting office.
If you get hypnotized by the thing
enough,
that's what it is.
Oh,
you want to fight it?
You want to fight for justice and I'll
tell you this now.
No,
you want to be noble.
You know what,
you don't want to work in the oil
fields.
You want to be noble straight to seal.
It was 30.
Think about a lot of people that are in
this country that are.
You got boring as shit town with no
fucking opportunity and you're
surrounded by a bunch of dummies and
then you go see this movie and you're
like,
Holy Shit.
But I think when you make a movie about
someone's life story,
and this is what I was pissed off at Fox
catcher for the same reason,
that movie foxcatcher about a John
Dupont who was that crazy old man who
shot a Dave Schultz who's an Olympic
champion wrestler and it was based on
his brother Mark Schultz in this one.
They fucked with everything in that
movie.
They.
He's so angry.
He's been Mark Schultz have been
tweeting like crazy because he's still
alive.
He's an Olympic gold medalist.
I mean that.
It killed him in the movie.
Well,
no,
no.
John Dupont killed the,
an Olympic gold medalist in the movie,
but his brother,
Mark Schultz,
who the book the movie and the book is
based on is still alive and they changed
all these aspects of his life for this
movie and he's like,
I'm still alive,
but this is me.
Like this isn't like a Chris Kyle thing
where they made the movie after he's
dead and who knows what,
you know,
he let put in and not put.
This is like mark was saying,
this didn't happen.
Like they messed with shit that didn't
even make sense.
Like they had the UFC in their movie,
but it was in 1988.
There was no fucking UFC until 1993.
I didn't even exist.
So they're watching an actual fight
between big daddy goodrich who was the
eventual opponent of Mark Schultz and a
lot of people like,
you're real good.
You're all read true view.
Nobody gives a shit.
It's a both.
The story.
No,
it's not dummy.
It's about history because why would you
make up any aspects of history when
you're doing a true story and you don't
need to change the timeline for the UFC.
That's totally arbitrary.
Like someone deciding to do that is
their own creative flair.
Just kissing,
just comping their balls and jizzing
over history.
If you did that with that.
How the fuck am I going to believe any
of the aspects of the story because you
lied about something.
I know you lied about.
This is weird shit where there's like
there's like this weird relationship
between the two and they're looking at
each other weird and he's wearing shorts
and now he's got frosted tips and people
were saying that it seemed like it was
gay and shoulds got really upset that
they were insinuating there was some
sort of a gay relationship.
They like fucked with the timeline of
his achievements too because he had
already won the world championships.
I mean he was already the best wrestler
in the world,
in his weight class and they were making
it look like,
like he needed his brother and he was.
He was sucking in,
dupont was,
his career was falling apart.
He was the best wrestler in his weight
class,
in the word mark.
Fucking show was an animal.
If you watch him wrestle when he was at
his peak form,
he was a fucking animal and like the
changed like the aspects of his
achievements in this movie,
like he was already a world champion,
like the way they made it and the way
they.
It's like the guy was fucked and nothing
was going right for him and then he
needed this John Dupont situation and
that's why he moved in,
in a beautiful mind when,
when,
when the wife stuck with them,
even though it was going crazy.
Yeah.
The real life.
She just left.
Of course,
soon as you run the bath water in the
kitchen,
I was like,
I'm out.
I'm divorcing you.
It's over.
Yeah.
It was like,
we're going to make it together.
Baby is American snipers that were going
to tell the whole story like what whole
story.
There was also a shitty father and
husband.
I thinking about the Ari Shaffir story.
When it comes out,
they're going to.
They're going to show him like with a
bag of mushrooms,
but he's like weeping as he eats.
I'm like,
I can't stop calling him.
Like Arya.
Got To stop eating those mushrooms.
No one is watching child porn.
Fuck you.
I don't even know why.
Why should it be legal?
I didn't fuck any kids.
Why isn't the video themselves legal and
put some words in your mouth.
Someone could could totally see.
Put it like on a newspaper quote or
something.
I have it come up.
Did you ever see lenny with Dustin
Hoffman?
You know,
I missed it.
I can see.
Look,
I'm a huge fucking Lenny Bruce Fan,
so I'm fascinated by.
I'm not a huge fan of is this is a
tricky way to say it because like I
think if I'm not endorsing what right
now,
I'm saying like if you go like have
lenny bruce is performing at the laugh
factory.
Knew what the comedy store.
I would tell people to go see you.
I would go because it wouldn't be freaky
just to see him,
but you're dealing with a completely
different era.
The world was just way different.
But anyway.
This is great.
Dustin Hoffman movie,
where Dustin Hoffman fucking nailed it.
He sounds just like lenny bruce.
I mean one of the few times where a
guy's on stage and it seems like he's a
real comic.
Huh?
It really,
it's really good.
But he says a bunch of Shit and you go,
did he say that?
How do I know?
He said that guy.
No,
you know,
I know you don't know exactly what came
out of his mouth at any given moment.
So a lot of this is just bullshit.
You know?
So like if you,
there's a real person,
you got to try your best to make
everything as on the money as possible.
Whatever you fill in has got to be
directly related to everything that you
absolutely know happen,
but you're not going to have to fill in
stuff.
Like when he tells his wife he loves her
for the first time,
it's like,
that's your,
like I'm guessing this heart one.
It's fine.
Unless the wife's alive and she can tell
you that could help.
But I think what you're talking about is
a controversial subject.
I think some people say that you got
creative license when things,
and you can say,
based on a true story,
it's.
This is a true story would look he's Ra
Ra all the way.
He's a flag waving old man.
He really is.
All those old men stick together.
We'll look.
I think this is.
I mean,
does it look.
I think Howard Stern,
just saying he enjoyed it as a movie.
It's supposed to be a very good movie.
It was like well made as a movie.
There was no story.
The acting was horrible.
There were some cool shit like fucking
sleeping shots.
This thing was cool and that was it,
but it wasn't much labeled.
He's not like a war,
like the one victim of bad guy wants to
get the whole time.
It's like I don't understand.
It's down to you,
man.
I think I've sat on the podcast called
Atlanta.
Here's what it boils down to.
You want to use military equipment,
right?
And a movie.
You're not going to get your own fucking
tanks and where are you going to get the
military equipment from?
You're going to get the military
equipment from the military and the
military and you can load that's over on
this.
They get to have script approval,
so the military,
they look through your script and they
make sure that the staff that is in your
script is going to get people down to
their local recruiting office and that's
why they let you use their machinery.
Don't use it to send them to cooper that
there's never been an antiwar movie that
hasn't made an enlistment go up.
Antiwar movie.
Yeah.
You feel like you literally cannot make
an antiwar movie because every single
depiction of war makes people go,
oh,
that's cool.
Like platoon,
all of it,
all of it.
You can see the trend right afterwards.
Enlistments shoots up after those big
movies tell you see the same front of
Ryan.
The guy gets blown up the close night,
but everyone's like,
I want to be a sniper.
You forget the fact they got blown up.
His people like being violent and this
is why Sebastian younger's book war is
such an incredible book because it.
It portrays war with no attempt to be
like,
this is right or this is wrong.
It just says if you take it.
I can't remember the exact wording,
but it's like if you take a 22 year old
and put them behind one of those giant
fucking southern.
Yeah,
it feels good.
It's fun to like.
It feels like that's Bob.
He pulled love violence.
So if you can figure out a way to get
people to be violent without the guilt
that goes along with like you're killing
other members of your species than what
do you do.
You create an imaginary story.
Right,
and the imaginary story in Iraq was the
weapons of mass destruction.
Also,
Saddam Hussein,
what they said this movie like,
Oh,
if I don't do my job to come to San
Diego and then knock on your door.
Apparently another aspect of the book
that has been the question is that the,
the barrels of weapons of mass
destruction that they found,
like he said that they found like
chemical weapons.
Right?
Really?
Oh.
He said we actually saw them laid eyes
on them,
but they're like,
well then why don't you tell anybody
what,
what do you mean?
Where's the enrichment?
Google search,
do a google search on birth defects in
some of the parts of Iraq that we attack
because we used a shells that had some
kind of radioactive isotope in it and
now the babies are being born with birth
defects because the other thing people
say is Saddam Hussein gas his own
people,
right?
He gets his own people.
Well,
what are we doing to them?
And we're dropping all these bombs.
Targeted strikes,
man.
They know exactly where they're heading.
No,
they don't.
People,
babies are being born with severe birth
defects because of what we did there.
So I think in a movie like that,
you need to at least illustrate the fact
that the reason that man was sitting on
the tops of buildings in that area,
killing them people was,
he was,
was because he was sent there based on
bad information to say the least.
And uh,
the people he's killing,
like in the very beginning,
it's like anybody over the age of 18,
this is anybody over the age of 18 in
this area.
This is an evacuation zone.
So there's no one except people that are
out to kill us.
It's all open game.
It's like,
oh wait a minute.
So you're saying that because the first
shot,
so don't worry about this question,
but morally know anyone who was there
over 18,
that's what they're there for.
Monsters did not leave the city that we
bombed,
that they lived in when we told them to.
So if they're still here,
kill and then still like shows
restraint.
And then when he found the house,
it was a kid,
but he has a fucking grenade launcher.
He waits until the kids running at the
fuck is about to throw it.
And then he shoots him.
But it's totally just shooting kid.
And then the mom,
what the fuck
and wait.
But why would they be angry?
I mean really?
Why would you be angry?
They only destroyed your city that you
lived in.
This is another thing of why we
shouldn't marines.
Why the Marines right there where they
can get shot,
remember thousands of miles away back to
America.
Well we were saying earlier about
ideologies are the problem and being a
nationalistic person,
subscribing and being a patriot,
subscribing to one nation only
regardless of what the actual act itself
is.
Looking at it like this.
Okay.
Because it's one of the books like that
is an ideology.
There you go.
That is as much of an ideology as a
religion.
It's an unquestioning thing.
Like,
you know,
one of the things that Michael Moore was
saying was that he put it on his
twitter,
his twitter that a sniper as a coward
and everybody got really pissed off.
You know,
like the,
I think the logic behind is kind of
silly.
Like you have to look them in the eye
when you shoot him.
Like shooting someone in the back is a
coward.
Like well in that sense 90 percent of
war is cowardly because you're,
you're saying some kind of wars.
Okay.
But some kind of what you have rules.
Yeah.
Look at somebody with or the back or
like what about a from 100 yards?
How about rock,
but that means no more rockets.
That means a lot of them want to do is
you're shooting people like you don't
necessarily look them in the eye when
you shoot them.
Are you having a dual?
Like what are you doing?
Standing back to back and walking 10
paces like assholes,
like what kind of is the reason to be
there?
Can you look at some of the negative
effects that we want to pull those back?
Like what if 30 percent of children the
Yemen have ptsd now because of drones?
I can't say that's a negative.
It's really important that that
information gets out there when you are
putting a movie out that's going to get
people in the same way.
Like when Beverly Hills Chihuahua came
out,
everybody bought a Chihuahua and the
pounds filled up with your hours because
they also have a sniper.
Is gonna do the exact same thing for
people who are a little confused on what
to do in their lives and they're going
to think,
well,
I guess the best thing I can do right
now is kill people that my government
tells me are evil.
Even though if I study the facts,
I find that it's a far more complex
issue than that and maybe my decision
should not be to become a hired killer
for people who are telling me that
actually killed people who more than
likely are innocent or just trying to
defend their home from an invading
occupying force.
It's really important to realize that.
Now.
I'm not saying all war is bad because
some people will be like,
you naive son of a bitch.
You don't even realize.
Let me repeat the speech.
At the beginning of American sniper,
this is what the day the speech,
so test.
Here's the speech the dad gives at the
dinner table after the American sniper.
What's his name?
Chris.
What was his name?
Because Chris Kyle is just defended his
brother from a beating by a bully and
they're sitting around the table.
His brothers got bruised up a little
bit.
Chris Kyle's sitting there and his dad
gives this.
There's three
types of people.
Hold on before you get the speech.
He goes,
I was just defending my brother and he
looks at the little brother with a black
guy and he goes,
is that true?
Like,
what do you mean?
Obviously he has a black guy.
He just got beat up.
That's right.
What a shitty movie.
Is that true?
He goes,
Yep.
It is three tax people in the world.
Three types.
There's sheeps.
Needs are the people who believe that
there aren't evil people in the world,
and by the way,
I'm paraphrasing your own.
These are the people who believe that
there aren't even people in the world
and that everything is safe,
and then there's the wolfs and these are
the people who try to use eval to
overpower others,
something like that.
And then there's the sheep dogs and
these are the people who defend the
sheep.
Oh God,
what are you going to be?
It goes,
if you're anything,
if you're the sheep or the wolf,
and he took his belt off and puts down,
will be fucked us up.
Your us.
Watch it,
man.
It is from the very beginning.
It's pure.
It really is like the way were talking
about how,
how,
uh,
soldiers are on their dying breath will
tell him.
I'm just glad I got to tell that story.
Telling that story.
Story,
story.
He told me.
I remember going around telling people
like y'all.
I met his,
his,
uh,
his fucking buddies and arms when he was
dying.
He was like,
you know,
I got married and at least I got it.
All right.
I would imagine if that really did
happen though,
that's,
that's Saturday than him lying.
Assuming it didn't happen,
but people are definitely dumb enough to
do that you don't understand about the
punisher tour of was magical.
Oh my God.
Wow.
That's fucking hilarious.
Last words,
you know,
like I'll be like,
but what about,
what about him stealing jokes?
His last words,
but he did it better.
Better,
better,
different in my country,
man.
Already I will give you $100,000
if on your death bed you say the least,
I got $200,000.
It would really give him 100,000
dollars.
And how would he use it?
He's dead.
Oh No,
you won't need this and I am one of your
best friends.
So aspiration.
At least.
Like I said,
I got that back by the way,
by storytelling show.
This is not happy.
Premieres this Thursday with Bobby
Meibomian Keegan key and
Dunkin.
We've done these extra stories that
we're doing for the web only they'll be
on youtube and Dunkin's premiering
tomorrow.
That's all right.
That's all I can tell.
A cool story about going to LSD trip.
Grateful dead concert.
Is there a reason they didn't want to
put that on television?
The to book another white male was
nearly impossible and too many white
males.
Did you need diversity training?
Yeah.
There was like,
who else can we get?
That's a little knock that out of your
way to look for non white males.
Yeah,
so it's a Jerry Seinfeld type situation.
Yeah.
They're like,
look,
we'll just going to get to attack.
If you don't get some others to attack,
it's just like bottom line.
It was just fucking pissed about that.
What is it?
The Oscars,
they don't have to get half,
but they just got.
You got to be representative.
That's so crazy about the Oscars.
It's all like all white people.
Black people are being excluded and less
Asian people are being excluded.
Joey does.
Yeah.
Those are both fucking ethnos,
but you can't have affirmative action
comedy.
Your account,
you're going to ruin the whole thing.
You can't do that.
You can't like you will.
Whoever's funny you got to say,
yeah,
but you get what you can do it like
this.
Like show me the pool of people that are
qualified and you show them 100 people,
like two of those.
There's only six blacks that are
qualified of those hundreds,
but pick two of them.
I don't mind being on the Internet.
I love the Internet.
Yeah.
That's where I live is on the flip side.
It can be way longer to just like we did
last year,
completely,
like don't worry about any.
The one that you put that we did that
was on the Internet.
It was great.
It was fun.
It was just actually before the show was
even on TV.
It's totally awesome to have something
on the Internet.
I was just confused as to the reasoning
for it because it came later to Eric,
the guy who runs it with me,
he was like,
Hey,
let's do it.
Also a web series,
the web series and that way goes to.
It's like if we show some short ones,
we want to bump somebody up.
We can.
If they're a good short story Rothbart
and with Ms Dot Pat.
You know what though?
It's fucking awesome about the web too.
It doesn't get canceled.
Doesn't get canceled.
It's on anytime you want.
It's actually a way better medium for
distribution.
Like a youtube channels.
Way Better.
Especially now you have youtube on apple
tv so you can go right to youtube.
Yeah,
I mean you can get youtube on a lot of
those little netflix.
You can watch tv,
you can watch them on your phone.
You can watch anywhere you want it.
If it's on comedy central,
you're going to be guaranteed a very
large audience,
you know,
like million plus audience of people
sitting there watching a lot of them
that aren't even your fans.
When you get good online,
you're going to get all of your fans so
they watch it more intently.
See your name right there.
It's way easier for them.
Like to fan wise,
we want to do it on TV.
Like okay,
that's a no weapons.
No,
no,
no.
Also all those stories go on the web.
Let's make a cool looking clip story
about trying to buy acid in a parking
lot on tv.
Exactly.
Like black,
white one that's great.
About some sex and a dog is involved and
they're like,
you're not doing beastiality on here.
Put It on the web though.
Like five golden.
I don't care.
As long as that area.
I just think the way,
like if
I get to choose.
Yeah,
doc had said that because I don't even
want to say like I'd rather be the wet.
You can say whatever the fuck you want.
Yeah,
I would.
for sure.
Because they,
cause he called me and he's like,
can we go through what your story is?
The idea being if we can,
like maybe we can make it so it could
possibly be on TV.
And I said,
oh no,
I just rather not be on TV because I
don't want to deal.
I don't want to worry about that.
I don't want to think about that because
the story I'm telling is a story about
being in high school,
trying to buy drugs and uh,
in just the worst slash best acid trip I
ever had in my life.
You don't even have to worry about
someone going,
can you make it sound a little less pro
the we won't get into it because I am
pro lsd and the moment they actually say
that maybe could happen,
you know,
like my special Ed.
Go do more drugs.
I do drugs.
What drugs?
Most rooms.
Other sort of like a bill look like
you'll never.
There's nothing ever bad happened to
you.
Bush gets in office.
That could be an issue.
Well,
yeah,
I mean there's a statute.
I mean,
you could it.
Could it be an issue?
Is that really loud cry all both.
You stop it.
You're going to get ideas in their
heads.
For sure.
She's talking about a schedule one
drugs.
Oh,
comedy central's heads that what you're
saying.
You're not worried about the
politicians.
Oh No,
don't be pussies.
You guys are rebels.
I think with mushrooms especially,
I think mushrooms like,
okay,
remember when marijuana was deeply
illegal,
way back in the day,
you'd fantasize with your friends about
the idea of marijuana becoming legalized
and you can see that it could be on the
horizon maybe,
but it was still kind of like,
it's never going to be legal.
It's a ridiculous dream.
I think mushrooms is the new marijuana.
Mushrooms is gonna.
Silicide.
Ben is going to become a prescription
medication that's given to people to
stop smoking.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
That's going to happen.
They'll wilson once,
once they start realizing that there are
medical benefits that they're looking
like they're proving that.
It's like they'll try to separate them
again.
Thank God for Doblin,
right?
Oh yeah.
He's at.
He's a champion hero.
That guy is a,
that guy deserves to be a,
deserves a Nobel prize for the work he's
doing for a second because he's doing
stringent hardcore studies proving that
many of these psychoactive compounds
have medicinals up.
Rick Doblin from the Multidisciplinary
Association for Psychedelic studies
maps.
It's just they do these like real stuff.
They will hardcore studies where it's
undeniable,
oh look,
what do you know silicide been helps
longterm smokers quit and when you
compare it to Chantix,
it's like the silicide minutes a million
times better because it'll help with my
depression.
Yeah,
it does.
It heals.
You,
changes the way your brain is
functioning you the path that you're on.
I think the past year on like someone
tried to explain this to me once a voice
try to remember the exact way it's
explained,
but that we want to think
of our moments as being moments
individual unto themselves,
but they're not.
They're a chain of unique moments
throughout your entire life.
Your interpretations of those unique
moments.
I'm paraphrasing the shit out of this
guy,
said it,
and then all of your associations with
life itself that are connected to your
interpretations of these moments and
then boom,
here you are today and you want to think
that this is life,
but it's only life because of all these
pathways that you've carved in the way
you view the world.
As soon as you change those pathways,
you open up a whole new world because
now your associations are different,
so now your brain's reaction to life
changing your route to work and almost
saying like,
oh,
look at these stores for your
in chemistry,
and it's such a great feeling when ever
any if that happens just slightly
because a lot of people are in a cave in
situation when it comes to their lives.
They're literally buried under a series
of antiquated,
stale symbols that they're looking at
the universe through and they feel
trapped.
It's like their shoes are too tight and
if like a psychedelic or meditating too,
and I really mean that.
I'm not just saying that to because of
that,
because I'm.
I really think meditation has a very
similar effect,
but any of these things,
they reset those symbols,
structures in your brain and if you just
like if you're in a cave in and you get
an extra inch compared to like being
compressed against the wall,
that's a big fucking deal man.
So it's slightly percentage difference.
Change change is like,
oh thank God I'm 13 percent less
frightened than I was for my entire
life.
Have you ever heard Tony Robbins talk
about changing paths in life is a really
interesting analogy.
He talks about like you're going to cars
going the exactly saying or a boat or
two boats going exactly the same
direction,
but one boat just takes a two degree
turn,
just two degrees here.
As they go further down the one boat
that took two degree turn is going to go
wider and wider away from the original
path and that each decision that you
make,
that's a good decision.
Takes you closer.
Like even though it's just like you're
just steering your ship,
just dirt as you go out.
It's going to be a much different path,
much different end than if you just
stayed on the original path.
That's incredible.
The different and psychedelics makes you
go right.
Turn Clyde,
looking at the.
The,
the,
the currents.
Try to bring you back though.
Yes.
Well Ego tries to keep the current kind
of bring it back to where you were gone
so it's got to take them a good.
Well,
I've always said get off that current
doing psychedelics.
It's like pressing the reset button for
your brain,
like control all the,
your,
your desktop reboots and there's only
one folder on the desktop that desktop
says the folder says my old bullshit and
you have two choices.
Either you just like create a completely
different desktop.
Look at reality,
a completely different or open up my old
bullshit and fall back into these
familiar patterns because they're very
comforting,
right?
You know in those moments after the
psychedelic experience are so important
to grab and hang onto because it gives
you this opportunity to make this new
way of thinking like a part of your
habit.
Once you get into that habit,
whether it's fucking,
you know,
the 30 days or 60 days or 90 days,
like people say that once you like have
a pattern ingrained in how you behave
and think and do it just takes a
consistent approach to that pattern and
then it becomes like an like a part of
you like that's why people quit smoking.
Like get past 90 days and you'll be all
right.
Right.
Jews say when you have,
if you go sit in the same feed three
times,
he's just keep sitting there.
That's your,
that's your do all time.
Suit.
That's smart.
Makes Sense.
When you take a psychedelic,
it's like if your life is a polluted
city,
like what are those polluted like what's
Detroit?
Detroit,
right?
And it's like the psychedelic all of a
sudden takes you in a helicopter outside
the pollution and so now you're seeing,
Oh God,
the air up here so fresh.
It's so nice.
But the thing is helicopters going to
land,
it's going to put you back out into your
city and that's where the job starts,
which is like,
shit man.
I don't remember if the city was wearing
like how can I clean this fucking thing
up and then that's,
that's like the,
that's when you start doing things like
exercising,
meditating,
or that's where you like create just a
very simple intention in everything you
do,
which is as much as possible.
I'm going to try to alleviate the
suffering of people around me as much as
I can,
you know,
not.
That might not be a lot.
It might just be call.
It might just be those two.
We got back from,
from this last UFC just a little bit of
mushrooms was enough.
I saw a homeless guy and he was looking
for.
I was like,
I open my wallet and I only have
twenties,
and I was like,
no,
fuck it.
There you go.
That's what it does.
And those little moments,
man,
it shows you that you get those moments
present themselves to you all day,
fucking long,
but if you are stuck in selfishness,
you don't see it.
Yeah.
It's real simple little things,
but it's fun.
It's a very wonderful.
That kind of simple intention can really
deep pollute your,
your subjective city that you've been
sucking in shitty gas.
There was one time I saw that I was the
only time I was looking for a guide to
somebody,
but it was Willie Hunter was on him and
he was shitting on following.
He was shitting on some like comic who
would become like a vine star,
you know,
she was a shitty comment,
but it became like a and he was like,
I hate falling.
We're like,
just for fun.
There's six second videos.
I was like,
no,
I hate him.
Like,
what about a six second youtube video?
Watch that.
I don't,
whatever.
He was just big,
shitty or like try to talk about it.
He wouldn't stop that.
We started with the mushrooms.
He was like,
I'm a bad person.
I never was like,
no,
you're fine.
And he kept doing it and eventually I
was like,
really?
Listen,
you're right.
That was you.
Being a bad person was like,
I'm so sorry.
There was like,
it's okay because here's the deal from
now on,
you don't have to be that anymore.
You can just let that go and let people
talk,
and he's like,
yeah,
that's what it shows you like you can
change,
but that thing you're talking about
where you realize,
shit,
I'm a bad person.
That is there is,
I can't remember.
Name and Buddhism.
There's an actual name for that and it's
considered to be a very sweet moment
where you need that moment.
It's virtualizer where you need that
moment where you look at your life and
you feel this very specific kind of
sadness because you look at all the
times you could have been kinder all the
times.
You could have called that person back
all the time.
You could have made decisions that were
pushing your boat in the direction of a
better world and you didn't do it and
you should feel sad about that,
but you shouldn't spend your whole life
feeling sad about it.
Right?
You should just spend some time there
and look at it and think,
okay,
well that's gone.
The past has been devoured by time.
There's only this moment now and so from
this point forward,
as much as I can,
my decisions are going to be based on
reducing the suffering of my species and
that means your trash before doesn't
mean you have to let her keep going
forever.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The,
the path of,
of trying to figure out like what's the
best way in life is obscured by law and
going amazing.
Like there's laws that they've created
that make the best tools to find out who
you really are illegal.
That's like there's not a therapy in the
fucking world that will get a crazy
sociopathic ego,
maniacal person to really look at
themselves like a bag of mushrooms.
Well,
there's nothing,
nothing.
All those moments in film with like,
Oh,
I realize now that's all bullshit.
Creating a mushroom trip.
People that you know that are
untrustworthy,
that you can't.
You can't.
Like,
you can't trust their stories.
You can't trust.
They're like,
those are the people that we all agree
could have like the best experience on
psychedelics because it'll give them
like the best view of themselves,
but those are the same type of people
that are going to argue against it.
Like if you ever talked to people that
don't want mushrooms to be legal or
don't want like,
oh,
but fuck that.
You think that should be.
You'll lose your fucking mind.
What about people who have lost her
fucking model now?
It's like what?
People have lost their mind.
What are you talking about?
Those 14?
There's been some people that have blown
their brains out with LSD for sure.
There's definitely been some people that
had some psychotic episodes and it can
be argued that a lot of those are
psychotic episodes are people who are
control freaks,
are egomaniacs that are struggling with
the reality that's presented with them.
Present it to them that you shouldn't
try it.
That's for sure.
People with a history of schizophrenia,
the family,
bipolar,
bipolar people,
they probably shouldn't try it either.
I mean,
there's probably a whole slew of people
who have abnormal human chemistry.
You know what else?
Bipolar,
people shouldn't try.
Caffeine really shouldn't take caffeine
pills.
Yeah,
you shouldn't do anything that's going
to push you into a manic state.
It's like we can't consider,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
the,
the victim thing about the victims of
psychedelics,
you know,
and I know you think climbing up,
what is it?
That math?
Yeah,
I think it's ridiculous,
but there is a valley there called the.
I just read about this on Reddit,
I think it's called.
There's an area,
I think it's called the valley of
rainbows and they call it that because
of the brightly colored jackets on the
corpses that are all laying there dead.
And I think psychedelics have the same
kind of valley.
I think that there is an undeniable
valley that must be filled with people
who have been pushed into psychotic
episodes or who are under the influence
of a psychedelic made bad decisions,
car accidents,
all the things that come from
irresponsibly using toxic.
You've got to admit that's real,
but just because that is real doesn't
therefore exclude all the people who are
saying again and again and again and
again.
Relationships are better,
so the marriages,
he even with alcohol or if there's some
trump terms don't trump drawing,
but it's pretty fun to get fucked up
with your friends once in a while you
got to look at the whole picture,
look at the whole thing.
Don't deny the fact that they're
dangerous chemicals and that people have
more than likely completely lost their
shit because of them.
Don't deny that,
but then also don't deny the benefits
and the same way with American sniper,
much better movie if that character was
actually dealing with the fact that he's
blowing people away in a war that has
been shown to be based on bad
information.
You think that when you get to be as old
as clinics with us,
don't you think to you or your faculties
have been compromised?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's almost 100 percent nothing thinking
the same way he was.
He's not as sharp.
No.
Honest million dollar baby was really
good.
Yeah,
but this is not that.
It's also,
it's the subject matter that he's prone
to go into these very right wing and
also you probably get over.
You can't separate your feelings.
He didn't have any feeling about women
boxers exactly.
Has deep feelings about this,
but it's got to be 100 percent raw Rah
Rah,
and it's like,
all right man,
now you're not.
Even if you were younger,
you're still wouldn't be able to see
this.
It's like when someone,
when someone talks like in their own
words and you get to hear them talk in
their own words,
you get a sense of like,
oh,
I see why you created this piece of art.
I see why this is your perspective.
And when you saw that the Republican
national convention thing,
whatever the fuck it was when he was
talking to Obama,
that's,
that's Clint Eastwood.
That was,
you know,
he.
So he's so fucking crazy that he thought
that up like on the spot.
That was ad libbed,
but you didn't even have anything
planned out.
This fucking guy is giving this speech
in front of this gigantic group of
people.
He's so confident in his ideas.
Then he's going to ad Lib a conversation
with Obama complete with punchlines.
Oh yeah.
He comes from a non video world to where
he's like,
man.
So it was a group of a thousand people
completely confident in his position in
life and who he is and he's a movie star
has been a movie star for fucking
100,000
years.
Everybody's been kissing his ass long
before the Internet came along.
He's also a guy that agreed to do a
fucking reality show.
Do you know that?
Where his wife was in a reality show.
His wife was in some crazy reality show,
man,
his wife,
I don't know if they're still together.
I think they might've got divorced,
but he wanted to be a star,
so she married when she was young and
hot and then she did a reality show.
Well,
I didn't know it.
Yeah,
it didn't last.
I'm not sure if he's still with her.
Has No real,
real cool.
I will look at worth it.
I looked up an interview with Eastwood
about directing the movie because I
didn't understand how the guy at the
Republican National Committee by this.
Oh,
well,
I mean I was just like,
Oh wow,
this is such blatant propaganda.
They're not even trying to make it
subtle.
This is just like war,
war,
time movie out of it.
Yeah.
That I was curious like,
okay,
I wonder how involved eastwood was in
directing this just based on what I saw
at the Republican national convention.
Didn't know it was improvised.
So now that kind of explains it.
I thought maybe he was just suffering
from senile dementia or something
called Mrs Eastwood and company.
It was on 2012.
It was a reality show.
So what the interview say though?
Well,
the interview was,
you know,
it was just him saying like,
he had actually been reading the book
when they called and he said,
let me finish the book.
I've got 40 pages left and so I read it
the next day and decided,
you know,
I was just a basic basic interview,
but I just,
it was just so appalled by that.
That was her.
It's pretty God damn hot that his wife,
it was his wife divorced him.
Of course he would marry a super hot
person.
She's hot as fuck.
Should compounds a wowza son.
Yeah.
Movie Star Yachty is what each expect.
You can't really say.
You also have some that.
Oh yeah.
I also have a story that's out on
youtube now.
My first story,
they put it out.
Beautiful smuggling we did in Australia.
Oh Shit.
Cool.
Don't talk about that on online.
What are you doing?
The beginning of it,
I should say,
this is all a lie you just got done
talking about.
Truthfully,
you should be our reality.
I don't do it anymore because the
results of this story,
but even then you could be like
admitting to an Interpol related crime.
I don't find any of that.
You're going to fucking have every bag
of garbage time and they have them like
locked up by date labeled so that if you
talk about something,
they can go back to the house and they
go,
we found it.
We found the bag.
We got the rappers,
best fucking kids on the pot and that
you brought those.
They'll find your DNA from the rapper,
from your sweat though,
isolate it,
and they'll bring you up into some sort
of tribunal.
The next time you try to go to Sydney.
Here's a little like care about that.
Just youtube search.
This is not happening already.
Smuggles weeding into Australia.
You can see it right now.
You are gangster sir.
You know man,
that makes me think it is a movie that's
coming out.
I'm really excited about.
Timothy leary's kid is releasing this
movie about his dad and and and Richard
Alpert,
but it's got all this like Bradley
Cooper Place Timothy Leary.
I heard.
What's that documentary?
Oh,
I see.
I missed it.
God
Damn it.
Sorry.
Totally.
That's such a slow ball too and I just
thought he was going to give you acid to
this kid and he wasn't going to.
But then the kid picked up a Bible so he
gave the kid acid.
Now this the real movies of this sniper
moment,
the kid is about to pick up the Bible.
I can't do it.
Gets the eyedropper and squirts in the
kid's mouth and you see the kids
eyeballs dilate,
falls back into a kaleidoscope and
Sufjan Jesus.
We hope you do to do something.
Probably worse.
Some of the more ridiculous than that.
What smart people will see through this.
Yeah.
That's not as watching this though.
Those sniper movies aren't really for
smart people,
but it's cool to watch clinches.
Timothy leary at the Senate hearings
apologized to my data.
Cool.
Watching him like having to talk to
Senate about lsd.
It's bad ass.
So he just,
you apologize to your date while we were
talking.
I was like,
ah.
So I thought that'd be better.
Sorry.
Just a poor pick.
Um,
uh,
you get to pick the next one.
That's hilarious.
Um,
there's a lot of stories about this and
I'm getting a shitload of tweets of
people asking me,
like to substantiate.
But there's a lot of stories.
It's all over online.
What are the Himalayan?
Yeah,
the weld.
The concerns are,
I can't say I don't know who the fuck
is.
Right.
And who's wrong?
I didn't do any research.
Clipped a jury to the jury,
decided that Ventura was right,
and then nothing else has been.
They owe him.
They,
oh,
I'm Jesse Ventura.
One point $8 million dollars.
Apparently one point eight,
one point 9 million.
Say one point seven,
one point seven feet with the fight.
So it's also crazy that that's how it's
never like one point eight,
one,
three,
seven,
4 million.
Like it's not exact amount is the pain.
How do they come up with it?
That narrowed it down to the close
800,000.
That's so weird.
Thousand to weird thing,
man,
to make a movie about a guy who might
have been a liar and put those lines in
a movie.
And that gets all miracle.
All frothy.
I mean,
well that means that,
you know what that means?
That means another fucking attacks
coming.
Does that what it means?
So we had to get salt orchestrated
because we've got to get people ready to
join up.
I don't think it's better than a draft.
I guess if you got to pick between that
draft and a,
uh,
that means for like ridiculous
propaganda movies coming out every year.
You know what I think?
I think you shouldn't have no wars.
We should fight no wars with anyone
under 50.
I think everybody who goes to war should
be over 50 lps.
Let's see.
Let's see how quick we fucking settle
this thing.
I bet it would be pretty God damn quick.
Oh,
a bunch of old people that just don't
want any trouble.
I mean he was like,
how can we,
is there a way to solve this without
shooting them?
It's like those feet on the ground.
He was coming at me and it's like,
okay,
but shooting him to death is the only
way to stop a guy because you think
about the consequences of the decisions
or think
about the consequences of a decision to
fly in a plane to a place where you've
never been and shoot someone he never
known based on the directions by some
people who you don't know.
We're making you march.
They're making you go,
shoo.
Shoo.
They're making you do all this shit
preparing you for.
You have to listen to them.
Unquestionably known.
Imagine that with 50 year old.
Yeah,
never going to happen.
We're going to go wait a minute.
Wait and why?
We're shooting these guys winning and
winning.
We're breaking down.
What door?
Who the fuck are you?
And where'd you go to school?
What's your degree in?
And you're going to tell me about
international politics.
Do you even know these fucking Sunni's?
What's the difference between the Sunni
and Shia?
Sir?
Tell me what the difference is.
Do you know?
Do you know why these people were at war
with each other?
Do you know why they hate each other?
Do you know how to hate us?
Do you know this is Holy Land.
Do you know how long this has been?
Holy Land.
Do you know when they're in?
If you had a group of 50 year old people
there and slug it.
I'm talking to you.
Oh,
you're allowed.
So I have to listen.
Is that what's going on?
Oh,
you don't have anything to say,
but you're going to get my face in spit
is that gonna make me intimidated and so
I'll listen,
so I'll just go and kill some people
that you say are bad.
If we did that,
if we just had only 50 year olds and
above go to war,
the whole fucking thing would change.
The whole thing.
It's just it's easy to send fucking
kids.
They don't know any better detail.
Your cerebral cortex,
your frontal lobe.
They're saying like for young males,
especially because fucking influx,
the rowdy or not making rational
decisions like when you're a 16 year old
kid,
your balls are filled with testosterone.
There's a completely new experience.
By the time you've got to be 40 years
old,
you've had a lifetime of wanting to
come.
A lifetime of like knowing what that is
and knowing how to mitigate it.
When you're 17,
18,
you don't know what the fuck is
happening to your body.
You add into that masturbation guilt
like people who were actually avoiding
masturbation.
Most of us don't,
but there are some who so they try it as
little as top of the white gloves on the
guns when they get comments,
when they put Megan where a white glove
around something.
Wasn't that a thing with white gloves
and someone who's not matched with that
going to blow this shit.
Every fucking one of those gopros under
over your bunk and if they don't see you
beaten off under the sheets,
I can fucking asked you questions.
Doctor,
do you want to come in here and talk to
us real quick?
You got anything on your mind like maybe
putting pussy or booties or something on
your mind.
You're trying to keep boys as social.
I'm just thinking about killing right
now was Duncan.
This is not the type of soldier will
good for and this here,
army,
we want well balanced individuals that
make rational choices based on the
evidence at hand,
not based on lust,
not based on a ball full of cum.
Just waiting.
A fucking g is all over some new part of
the world to spread your fucking seed.
My gun is my cock bullets.
Serum Ige is and the brains of my job
are my pussy.
Oh my God.
And best moving to either go jim's dead
bro Bro Bro,
when you get up and leave,
but like are you going to call me on
American if I just think the filmmaking
of this as bad.
Manipulative.
It is like you want to walk out,
but simultaneously you feel like you're
being.
You want to go to 18 on this.
This is kind of done this in an hour.
I our 26 to 18
embarrassing.
If this turns out that this guy really
did make up all this shit because
there's another article I'm looking at
right now about the criticism of the
Post Katrina in New Orleans story.
Like how it's all total horseshit.
How they can prove it tore shit cause he
wasn't even there at that time.
Oh yeah.
It's like there's a lot of horseshit.
You mean there's,
there's,
there's facebook and in the movie it's
all.
He's just trying to downplay all of his
legend even though he's now.
It's like he's the one who was saying
it.
Don't fall for this if you're wrong,
good luck.
Good luck her.
I'm not supposed to.
I'm not going to do out here,
but for all of you,
for it,
they'll fry you,
put you in life.
And why aren't you looking at the
spotter?
Look,
you an Iud.
Will you just crouching behind a wall?
I just fucking up his shot looking at
extra pressure on this.
There's a facebook page not endorsing
this.
I'm just letting you know this dedicated
entirely to the subject and it's Chris.
Kyle was a murderous liar.
It's a community on facebook and it's
all a bunch of different posts saying
that,
you know,
saying how much it was bullshit.
This is crazy,
man.
Yeah,
I guess people don't want to.
It's really hard for people to digest
the simple fact that Pete,
that war makes a lot of money for a
small amount of people.
It's a profitable endeavor.
And uh,
if you want to make money in that
industry,
then you've got to convince heroes
because that is the heroic ends.
It's a really sweet mpulse the idea that
I will give my life for you to protect
you,
to protect people.
I don't know.
That's the one of the highest human
aspirations.
It's like an incredible thing,
but so you take those people who have
this incredible aspiration to give their
life to protect people and you lie to
them and brainwash them and send them to
a place to kill people based on this
very incredible thing and leave the nfl
and fucking give us.
And by the way,
well no,
Pat Tillman did it on his own.
We need you to do this.
But Pat Tillman was a huge critic once
he got over there,
the,
you know,
he was killed by friendly fire and
there's many people that have speculated
they murdered him,
that murdered him because he wouldn't
shut the fuck up.
Organize.
Everything was about what a dog and pony
show and everything was fucked up.
The people that are to listen to,
we're all assholes.
Who was like,
this is crazy.
Like this is not what I signed up for.
This is not what I wanted to
be in total chaos,
which led to this fucking crossfire
situation.
It killed fucking talent to stop
shooting and then they shot him.
They shot his whole troop up.
Though,
I mean,
look,
when you start shooting things,
that's the other thing.
It'd become target and then say we've
become targets.
They don't comment on drone mistakes.
They don't comment on the times when
it's.
It blows up a fucking wedding
convention,
which is most of the time that's why
there's more mistake,
the innocence and that our policy is not
the comment on that.
Like,
wait,
why is that an allowable policy?
Yeah,
the percentage is terrifying.
If you look at the percentage of people
that are actually killed by drones that
are their intended targets,
it's terrible.
It shouldn't be terrorists,
but they're not surgical strikes.
How close is it?
You're not.
It's not a scalpel on the end of a
fishing pole,
you know?
It's just the idea that surgical is
retarded.
If we had drones going overhead and then
I found out who's responsible for it
yet,
and I'm a little kid,
I'm like,
this is fucking Yemen drone that's over
here.
Killed my kids.
Like,
Goddamn right,
I'm going to want attack Yemen.
Stop fucking set of that shit over here.
It killed my father.
Yeah.
Well,
not only that,
but why wouldn't they want to know?
If you look at the,
like we were talking earlier about what
you were saying about this,
these invading armies in Iraq and the
other people that have ptsd and the
birth defects.
You've got to go way back to the
original Gulf War.
They were using fucking depleted uranium
and everybody forgets about this.
Everybody completely sweep this under
the rug.
It was proven.
They use depleted uranium shells that
blew right through fucking tanks.
This incredibly dense nuclear waste that
poisons everything around it for 100,000
years and that was 25 years ago.
We're expecting those 15 year olds who
were the 40 year olds now to go,
oh well I don't care anymore.
No big deal,
but not just forget about that time.
You killed my entire family.
Oh,
and you're right here.
Someone representing your governments
right here.
Totally cool,
but it's something that we're not
supposed to talk about.
Just like the ideologies that we just
discussed earlier,
just like religion,
it falls into a religion.
Got To talk about Elysium falls into a
religion.
Don't all start talking about it,
but you can't talk about it.
Well,
it's also because there are bad people
keep talking about the weed.
It's like that's why it's all lead
because I've got another deal,
right?
Everyone talks about becomes normalized.
You got to just talk about it all time.
Exactly.
You're friends with whatever and it
doesn't mean that you're done.
This is where people get confused.
It doesn't mean that there aren't heroes
and doesn't mean you don't need a
defense.
You don't need to be able to protect
yourself from some fucking North Korean
asshole.
That guy decides to start taking over
the world.
Like what if they had massive resources.
We're lucky they're in a resource
starved environment,
so you have this communist dictator with
nuclear weapons that a resource starved
environment where they have to shut the
lights off at night because they can't
afford to keep them on,
but if that guy had oil or gold or
something crazy and like Saudi Arabia
type money,
if like one of those guys became some
sort of a fucking world spreading
villain,
you need heroes.
You need real soldiers that are willing
to fight against bad people.
That's what happened in World War Two,
World War II when you had the Nazis and
all that.
I mean,
I'm sure there's all sorts of flexes.
They use the justified war,
uh,
argument as proof to get us into sort of
less way less justified war.
We're sending them to the best thing to
happen to the US army.
When we're saying,
look,
now we can do anything.
We just say we're doing the right thing.
Exactly what is exactly the same thing
we were saying about religion is that
it's not that these people are bad
people and it's not that God is bad.
No one's saying that.
But what we're saying is like,
look what's being done in the name of
this and look how there's no thinking.
Whenever there's no thinking and
horrific acts are being done,
there's no thing.
If you're ever in a situation where a
fucking little kid has a rocket
launcher,
everybody should stop what they're
doing.
Get the fuck out of there and try to
figure out a how.
How did this happen?
Or B,
how do you fix it and the way you don't
fix this,
but shooting kids that doesn't fix shit
that just like the mother is doing now.
Oakland PD is starting up like Youth
Basketball Leagues and they're coaching
and stuff to so the youth grow up.
Not going fuck the police,
but like,
no,
the police were cool there.
Help sell it and stuff.
That's like,
you can't solve it right now,
but 20 years from now it'll be better
than it is now.
Will also.
What's happened in New York when they
did the police slow down where they just
wouldn't arrest anybody for anything.
After those two kids got,
oh,
there's two cops got shocked by that one
guy,
that one guy who by the way also shot
his fucking ex girlfriend,
like the guy was a piece of shit to
people to think he's a hero.
Like Jesus Christ.
He shot his girlfriend first and then he
went and shot those cops.
He was a psychotic murderous person,
but because of that act,
the cops backed up.
The cups finally started.
Stopped fucking with people they need to
stay where they're at right there.
Yeah,
exactly.
What?
Where they are right there.
Cameras.
Are you finding this camera's not saying
that they should be scared all the time
of being murdered,
but I'm saying the attitude that they
devote like,
okay,
we're not going to arrest anybody for
anything.
That's not important.
That's all you should have ever been
doing.
Exactly.
New Collector.
It's illegal to sell cigarettes outside,
so tell them to get lost or don't.
You'll shake them down.
How about you hire a fucking lawyer to
go sue that guy and then you find out he
doesn't have any money.
He's not gonna pay anyway.
There's your problem.
You got a problem with tax collecting.
You don't have a pr.
If that guy rob somebody,
then you bring it up,
Jay walking and he comes in and he
breaks into your house and steals your
TV.
Then you have the cops,
but anything,
any use of that other than protecting
people.
Fucking choking a guy because he's not
paying cigarette tax.
What the fuck are the cops?
It's not like New York plunged into
chaos,
but as they started enforcing,
write him a ticket.
You don't much nicer.
The world would be if cops only acted in
that slow down manner,
but they don't act like that with big
black man.
There's a huge racism.
It would be incredible.
Don't act though where you've been there
over the last few months.
You moved there like half the uh.
What is your experience like at the
difference racism out here as opposed to
erase all joined in here.
We're wastes more separated,
but
it's like,
I don't think we see shit like why
people don't even see the.
Like they're constantly getting like,
you don't want resisting.
Arrest is,
was this the residence after the first
time someone's like,
Hey,
let me see your Id.
And they grab you and they push you.
The second time the same shit happens.
A cop pushes you the fourth time out of
your car and they grab your wrist and
go,
c'mon man.
If you pull back,
you've resisted arrest.
Wow.
Come on mom.
I'm late for a movie.
What?
Let's just talk about this first.
You've resisted arrest,
right?
It's up to their discretion whether or
not they choose to arrest you or known
restaurant people.
Some people get off on the exact same
charge and they skate.
Whereas other people get arrested like a
year old white guy with a suit and you
do a certain thing to stop and Frisk was
based on stop and Frisk people,
Latinos and blacks who looked like they
might have some shit.
Right.
You didn't see it on Wall Street.
You didn't see them.
Of course,
to getting stopped and frisked on Wall
Street on Wall Street weren't as
outraged about it.
Stop and Frisk for shit that shouldn't
be illegal in the first place.
So that's like illegal search.
It's like saying we're going to just
search you,
but we have no reason to search it and
well,
he could have been weapons,
right?
We shouldn't say we're looking for
weapons they're looking for.
I mean it's dope,
man.
They want to get you for that.
Arrested you for dope or something that
grows out of the earth that help scans.
I'll be honest,
if I.
Yeah,
if I'm a cop and I don't like you and I
see something,
even if I don't think it's wrong,
if I'm a 23 year old,
I'm like,
well,
I'm going to put you in jail now.
Meanwhile you don't even think it's
wrong.
Wall Street guy with a leather bound
briefcase,
it has your in your engraved with your
initials and your family crest on it.
They pull you over,
they stop and Frisk,
you pop open,
you see a bottle of pills,
heroin,
pills,
but on that bottle has your name on it.
They will see heroin,
but I've registered.
You've registered,
you've paid your taxes.
The king got his price up.
This doctor as well,
you know,
I know that people would abuse their
privileges based on stuff they don't
believe in.
We have a comedian's basketball league
and role playing and if it's directly
they call technicals on curses and stuff
and so if you hear somebody.
Yup.
Well they don't know what the comedians
league.
There's.
We just made her own comedians league,
but if we hear somebody cursing some
other committee,
if I hear fucking Jeff Dye curse,
I'm cars,
the cars and we all try to get a
technical shit.
No comment believes they should be not
allowed.
Right?
But isn't that just for fun?
Like,
but we want the fucking benefit.
We're going to use our power so we don't
believe in 23,
somebody goes,
fuck you cop.
Like,
well I'll look at anything I can to put
you in jail right now.
That would be like if we were playing
pool and I go,
oh,
it's fucking shot.
Oh,
give me Paul enhance.
Exactly because I cursed and you
actually ask for it.
No,
no,
no.
Dude,
you gotta give me a bond in.
Be a decline.
That rule.
Douchey came.
You guys do that playing basketball.
You need to stop.
You need to get on mushrooms and think
about that call and technicals like that
or not having your jersey.
I'm like,
we're comics.
Nobody remembers to wash the Jersey and
it's only comics playing against comics.
We made our own league.
So you know,
it's an open mic at least to get on that
thing.
Hilarious.
We have one team,
we call them the,
the corporate sellouts and that's all
the agents and managers.
That's funny.
Yeah.
You know what you should do.
You should recruit really fucking good
players and just get them to do an open
mic.
Glassman shit.
That's what he does.
And he gets them to do one of the mic.
Like No.
The point is the play,
the game of comics while having fun
playing games with will used to have a
comics,
have a softball league back in Boston.
Really?
Oh my God.
He would get so competitive.
It was so crazy.
It was like competitive people screaming
at people over fucking fouls or,
or were ball was in the ball was out,
you know?
I was like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
I remember like people in each other's
face throwing the gloves down,
screaming at each other.
A comics bat baseball game.
But that's Boston Davey babies without
their bottles.
I was back at Boston that they fixed
that club,
that laugh.
Boston sound system is awesome.
Okay.
You don't have to worry about it anymore
on the automation because everybody had
that rumor that was out at the sound
system.
Sucked is loud as fuck it did feedback
once when I got like on top of the,
the,
the actual speaker was talking about.
But that happens almost everywhere,
you know,
unless it's perfect.
It's something the Improv does you.
There's never a fuck up if you're
working in Improv.
Like if the sound system's always
perfect,
the seeding is always perfect.
There's never sight line issues.
They don't ever fuck around.
Like you know,
some clubs that your work out there kind
of funky.
Like if you stand on one medium so you
can't even see flyballs yeah.
But it was worse because there's often
pillars in the room and if you're behind
that pillar and you will go to the right
side,
like the people that are behind that
pillar literally can't even see you.
Like they're there,
but unless they're,
they have to watch monitors in a club.
The improv has that nailed.
They always say like,
nap.
You got to set this up like that.
Like all of them are like,
nope,
set it up like that,
but this way it's got todd glass level
approval.
Tagless,
helium,
helium.
He helped them design a place with
helium in Philly.
Listen,
I got to go.
Can I say something real quick?
I'm going to be doing a live Duncan
trussell family,
our podcast on the 25th,
which is this Sunday in Dallas,
Texas,
and take it links are at my website.
Laura Duncan trussell alive.
Duncan trussell family.
Johnny Johnny Pepper police telling me I
can go with.
What was it this weekend?
It's this week and this Sunday I'm going
to be in Dallas and then I'm doing Ostin
and they come and take it comedy
festival,
which is in Houston too soon as it
called the what to come and take it to
takeover festival.
It's on my website.
If you're in Texas,
come out and see a podcast.
Comedy Central.
This is not happening.
Premieres this Thursday.
Every Thursday at 1230 after midnight
for eight straight weeks.
Boom.
Eight different openings that directors,
crazy boom son.
And on top of that,
the other videos available on youtube,
on go to.
This is not happening on Youtube.
Just enter that.
They should all be coming up.
Good.
Googly Mowgli and Jenkins will be out
tomorrow.
My new ones today.
All right,
I'm gone all week.
No more podcasts.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Thanks everybody.
See you soon.
[inaudible] a Jew.
January 30th.
I'm at the Mirage in Las Vegas again,
back at the Mirage,
but Tony Hinchcliffe and Ian Edwards,
so we'll see that.
All right,
much love.
Bye Bye.